We won't take your cash, you gotta pay with plastic. If you have a coupon then that's fantastic, we know you're ready to get to new places. Thank you for the fact that I wasn't ignored.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Ausgabe Nummer 187. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, meine Podcast-Reise, die hier gerade stattfindet, hat eine weitere Etappe genommen und ich befinde mich in Hildesheim, um ja auch wieder so ein ewiges Thema mal hier abzuhaken, was auch schon ganz lange im Hinterkopf lag. Ja, genau, es soll es gehen, um ein Flugzeugprojekt, das heißt Paparazzi und um darüber Auskunft zu geben, begrüße ich Martin Müller. Ja, Martin, Flugzeuge im Bauch, wie kommst du dazu?
Mein Großonkel hat vor und während des Krieges Flugzeuge gebaut und dann irgendwann Modellflugzeuge gebaut und der hat mich dann auch dazu gebracht, malen Modellflugzeuge zu bauen und zu fliegen. Also der hat aber so richtige, so richtig große, wo man so drin sitzt und wo man irgendwelche Sachen mitmacht. Und der hatte das dann immer noch so nebenbei. Nach dem Krieg durfte man keine Flugzeuge mehr bauen in Deutschland und der hat mich dazu gebracht, Modellflugzeuge zu bauen. Dann kam irgendwann die Idee, dass man da auch mehr mitmacht und vielleicht Kameras einbaut oder vielleicht das Bild von oben runtersende, dass man sich das unten angucken kann. Das war dann so vor 10, 15 Jahren irgendwann möglich. Dazu kam dann irgendwann dieses Paparazzi-Projekt, wo ich auch nicht von Anfang an dabei war, wo man dieses Flugzeug nicht nur mit Kamera ausstatten konnte und sonstigen Sachen, sondern auch das Flugzeug selber fliegen lassen konnte.
Also langsam gesagt, mit Modellbau fing es an. Aber er hat so richtige Flugzeuge gebaut.
Das waren so Leichtflugzeuge. Das eine stand neulich im Deutschen Museum. Ein Flugzeug, was dem Vorgänger von Ultraleichtflugzeugen vielleicht entspricht, was man heute so hat. Also was besonders leicht war, besonders viel Auftrieb hatte.
Also mehr so experimental?
Ja, an der Universität. Leichtflugzeuge hieß das Institut für Leichtbau. Das waren besonders leichte Flugzeuge. Also das war mehr so die Maschinenbau-Gegend, während ich eher so Elektrotechnik, Elektronik, Computer, C64, so aus der Lehrrichtung kam und das dann in das Flugzeug reingebracht habe.
Und dann bist du mit Modellflugzeugen durch die Gegend geflogen?
Ja, erstmal mit Modellflugzeugen, aber dann nur so lange ich zu Hause war, so mit Studium und ohne Auto und ohne Flugzeug war das dann schwierig. Und dann fängt man irgendwann wieder an zu arbeiten, kann sich ein Auto kaufen und dann fängt es wieder an, dass man Flugzeuge, dass ich Flugzeuge geflogen habe.
Aber dann will man sie irgendwie nicht mehr selber fliegen.
Naja, das ist ja doch ziemlich cool, wenn das Flugzeug dann nicht nur auf dich reagiert, sondern du stehst da unten und es fliegt da so seine Kreise und es fliegt mal zehn Meter höher und das Flugzeug fliegt zehn Meter höher oder lande mal und das Flugzeug landet. Was gibt es Großartigeres?
Was ist denn mit diesem First-Person-Moment, was ja viele auch machen, ist so Kamera einbauen und dann Brille auf und dann hat man so dieses Cockpit-Feeling, dass man selber so drin sitzt.
Das hatten wir eigentlich vielleicht sogar schon vorher. Also bevor es Paparazzi gab, haben wir so kleine Videokameras eingebaut und dann so analoge Videosender und so einen kleinen Schirm. Aber es gab damals noch nicht wirklich taugliche Brillen, die man sich so umschnellt. Das heißt, du hast so ein Tageslicht immer in diesem Monitor, hast da nicht so wirklich was gesehen und das war irgendwie ungünstig. Deswegen war das damals noch nicht so der Reiz. Also das kam da so auf, aber wo das so bezahlbar war, fing das mit Paparazzi an und dann war das nicht so. Also wir können das auch machen, vielleicht sogar noch schöner, weil du kannst dann FPV, also First-Person-View fliegen, indem du virtuell durch das Flugzeug betrachtest, was es macht. Und kannst dann noch auf den Knopf drücken sagen, jetzt ist es aber komisch, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo das ist. Und dann fliegt das halt automatisch wieder zurück. Das kannst du auch noch schön kombinieren. Aber so wirklich die Anwendung hatten wir dafür nicht. Und das ist dann irgendwann auch langweilig. Wenn du da auf dem gleichen Modellflugplatz immer rumfliegst, dann weißt du, wie jeder Baum und jeder Strauch aussieht. Und diese FPV-Videos, die es so im Netz gibt, da geht man ja schon zu Orten, wo es auch was zu sehen gibt. Also in Alpen oder auch auf dem Potsdamer Platz, wo man dann da rumfliegt. Und das haben wir eher nicht so gemacht, sondern wir sind auf unserem Modellflugplatz geblieben. Und das war dann irgendwann langweilig, dann kennst du das.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. So, wie bist du dann zu diesem Paparazzi-Projekt dazugestoßen?
Es gab 2004 eine Konferenz in Braunschweig, EMAF hieß sie damals, die European Micro Air Vehicle Conference, da waren Antoine und Pascal und haben Paparazzi vorgeführt. Das sind so Wettbewerbe, bei denen es darum ging, damals einfach nur autonom zu fliegen. Da wurden so vier Punkte aufgestellt und da musste man dann im Quadrat fliegen autonom. Das fand damals in Braunschweig auf dem Flughafen statt, mitten im normalen Betrieb zwischen Paten und Learjets und so was. Und kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen heutzutage. Und das war nach 2001. Das fand aber damals so statt und es gab wenige Teams. Es gab von der Hochschule Flugzeuge. Es gab von der EADS, glaube ich, damals EADS-Forschung Flugzeuge. Also das war schon eine große Sache. So ein kleines Flugzeug, also Microsoft Air Vehicle, damals war das Limit zu 50 Zentimeter, so ein kleines Flugzeug selbst fliegend überhaupt hinzubekommen. Das war damals nicht so wirklich trivial. Und dann habe ich im Netz geguckt und habe die gefunden. Und das war alles open source und dann E-Mail geschrieben. Und dann war ich irgendwie dabei.
Auch wenn du jetzt nicht von Anfang an dabei warst, wie hat sich das Projekt dann überhaupt so entwickelt? Also wer hat das begonnen und warum?
Das waren Pascal und Antoine. Die waren 2002 in Toulouse bei dem dortigen Wettbewerb der Universitäten und wollten das selber machen. Dann bei Antoine im Garten. Der wohnt auf so einem Berg, da kann man wunderbar fliegen. Das war auch später super. Man konnte drinnen hacken, rausgehen, fliegen, wieder reingehen, noch was hacken. Dann haben die angefangen, Flächenflugzeuge autonom fliegen zu können. Anfang 2003 funktionierte das dann. Dann gab es die ersten Veröffentlichungen, alles unter GPL. Sowohl die Hardware als auch die Software, die sie dafür entwickelt haben. So sind sie dann von einem Wettbewerb zum nächsten. Sie haben mit ihrem Paparazzi-System teilgenommen. Sie haben versucht, das immer weiter zu optimieren. Auf die Anforderungen, die es in diesen Wettbewerben gab, wurde dann immer mehr. Man musste den Terroristen im roten T-Shirt erkennen. Man musste hinterher den Paintball abwerfen. Oder man musste den Buchstaben am Boden lesen. Oder den Buchstaben im Boden eingefasst in einen Zaun.
Das ist ja schon ein bisschen Military-Style jetzt alles.
Das war zu Beginn recht Military-Style. Das ist es auch immer noch so ein bisschen. Es gibt gerade auch in Deutschland viele Leute, die diese Wettbewerbe, gerade EMAF, die es immer noch gibt, meiden, weil da auch immer Militär ist. Das war schon ein universitärer Wettbewerb oder ist ein universitärer Wettbewerb. Aber so ein bisschen Militär läuft da halt auch rum. Das war jetzt nicht so, dass sie dann gleich einen mitnehmen oder dass die irgendwie Flugzeuge kaufen wollen oder so. Die wollen einfach nur sehen, was geht. Anstatt mit dem Internet sich die Bilder anzugucken, was die Leute machen oder die Filmchen, gehen sie halt dahin gucken, was so an den Universitäten geht und was man so machen kann.
Ich meine, dass sich das Militär mit dem Thema auch schon etwas länger auseinandersetzt, als das andere Leute tun, ist ja auch jetzt kein Geheimnis. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie dadurch erst darauf aufmerksam geworden sind. Drohendenproblematik wird ja auch jetzt zunehmend, denke ich, auch ein gesellschaftliches, politisches Thema. An der Stelle ist vielleicht auch noch mal Wert, auf eine alte CRI-Folge hinzuweisen. Ausgabe Nr. 106 hat sich ja auch schon mit dem autonomen Flug etwas beschäftigt, das Mikrokopterprojekt. In dem Fall halt Quadrocopter, die gegenüber den normalen Flugzeugen den Vorteil haben oder zumindest die Eigenschaft haben, selbst stabilisierend einfach so in der Luft zu stehen. Was ja jetzt so ein normales Flächenflugzeug, wovon wir jetzt bei Paparazzi reden, jetzt so erstmal nicht kann.
Es gibt auch bei Paparazzi Quadcopter, also auch schon relativ früh. Ich bin mit Antwans Quadcopter irgendwie 2005 das erste Mal geflogen. Das lief immer so ein bisschen parallel. Wir haben uns aber auf die Flächenflugzeuge konzentriert, weil es mit den Flächenflugzeugen einfacher zu realisieren war, klein zu bleiben. Also unter den 50 cm oder am Ende der letzte Wettbewerb, den wir so richtig aktiv mitgemacht haben, war 2008 in Indien. Da hatten wir so einen Flieger, der war so DIN A4 groß. Da ging es dann langsam los, dass es auch mit Quadcoptern zu schaffen war. Oder inzwischen hat man das ein bisschen...
Aber das was zu schaffen war...
.dass man so klein wurde. So ein Quadcopter, den man sucht, ist ein Mikrokopter. Die sind ja eher so im Gesamtabmaß so 70-80 cm groß. Und die Gesamtabmaße unter 50 cm zu bekommen, war damals nicht so wirklich zu machen mit dem Quadcopter.
Aber das ist jetzt nur irgendwie so eine beliebige Größeinschränkung. Man hätte ja auch sagen können, Blatt unter 70 cm. Ist da irgendwas anders dann?
Die Wettbewerbe wollten halt diese 50 cm. Und das war auch, worum es halt ging. Also grundsätzlich ein autonomes Flugzeug zu bauen, war nicht mehr so das große Ding. Aber das halt sehr klein zu machen, war halt damals noch nicht so einfach. Und deswegen haben wir die Quadcopter damals nicht so gemacht und sind auf Flächenflugzeuge gegangen.
Autonomes Fliegen, du sagst jetzt gerade, war jetzt nicht mehr so das Ding. Ich meine, das erste, was einem gleich so einfällt, ist so Autopilot. Ich weiß nicht seit wann haben Flugzeuge Autopilot wirklich, dass die selber komplett selber fliegen können, also die großen Verkehrsflugzeuge?
Also meine gab's schon, also die V2 im Zweiten Weltkrieg war ja ein Autopilot, die fliegt auch irgendwie eigenständig irgendwo hin. Also grundsätzlich ist so Autopiloten nicht so das große Ding. Es gibt von der Air Force so eine Historie, wer wann was wo gemacht hat. Und da hat man in den 40ern, 50ern oder den 60ern mit Überschallflugzeugen über China oder Russland versucht, Aufnahmen zu machen. Also das Thema selber ist schon relativ alt. Was jetzt so neu reinkam, war, dass man das so klein machte und vor allen Dingen so günstig machte, indem man auch Modellbau-Komponenten verwendet und das Computertechnik so klein wird, Modemtechnik, Kameras, alles. Die Sensoren, die man dafür braucht. Dass es eben auch für normal Leute oder für Normaluniversitäten oder wer auch immer das macht, bezahlbar ist. Dass es eben nicht nur das millionenteure Militär machen kann. Wobei das Militär jetzt also auch unsere Unterstützung wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich braucht. Weil die Milliarden für die Forschung ausgeben, brauchen die nicht so ein paar Hobbybastler, die ihnen zeigen, wie man Drohnen baut.
Ja, vielleicht, um ihnen zu zeigen, wie man das ohne Millionen macht. Wenn die dann auch nicht mehr so fließen.
Das war mal ein Argument, wo mal jemand sagte, dass das ein gutes Ding wäre. Paparazzi, das würde helfen, die kommerziellen Millionen Leute runterzudrücken. Weil zu sagen, hier gucken sie doch mal. Paparazzi, die können das ja auch günstig.
Gut, das Ziel war autonomer Flug, kleine Flugzeuge. Und die Wettbewerber sagten einfach nur, wir hätten es gerne in klein. Und es wäre ihnen dann egal gewesen, was das Flugprinzip ist.
Genau.
Also man hätte es genauso mit einem Quadrocopter, mit einem normalen Flächenflugzeug. Ich weiß nicht, gab es noch andere Ansätze? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es gibt jetzt so eine kombinierte Geschichte. Quadshot heißt das? Zeppeline. Das ist bei Wind und Wetter eher unschön. So eine Kombination aus einer Fläche, wo man vier Motoren dran schraubt. Der startet dann wie ein Quadcopter und fliegt dann mit der Fläche weiter. Weil das ein Problem zwischen dem Quadcopter und dem Flächenflugzeug, der Unterschied ist, dass du ja bei dem Quadcopter die Luft nach unten rauspustest und sie weg. Und beim Flächenflugzeug segelst du ja einfach nochmal. Das ist so energetisch grob, so Faktor 2, 2,5 oder so. Und vielleicht so der Unterschied zwischen Laufen und Fahrradfahren. Wenn du läufst und hörst auf zu laufen, bleibst du stehen. Wenn du den Berg hochgefahren bist, brauchst du nicht mehr treten. Du brauchst vielleicht noch ein bisschen Energie, um gerade runterfahren zu können und nicht umzufallen. Das heißt, deinen Akku ganz oben leer zu machen. Keine gute Idee. Aber du kannst die Energie noch nutzen. Und das war dann bei einigen Wettbewerben auch von Vorteil, dass du die Flächenflugzeuge nutzen konntest, um weiter zu fliegen, größere Strecken abzufliegen. Auch in der zivilen Anwendung von Vorteil.
Da kann man dann auch irgendwo hinfliegen, wo man es noch nicht kennt und wo es nicht so langweilig ist, sich das alles anzuschauen. Ja. Das heißt, was hat man dann genommen für Flugzeuge am Anfang? Hat man sich das normalen Modell, der normalen Modellbauflugzeuge, die man sonst auch per Fernbedienung gesteuert hat, bedient? Oder noch andere?
So kleine Flugzeuge sind nicht üblich beim Modellbau, weil das Problem ist, du fliegst ein bisschen weg und siehst es nicht mehr. Deswegen haben wir eigentlich von Anfang an Flugzeuge selber gebaut in den verschiedensten Typen, Styropor oder so ein gummiartiges Styropor oder in Glasfaser oder in in Depron. Das ist so eine andere, so eine Tapetenisolierung eigentlich. Da haben wir Flugzeuge mal daraus gebaut. Kevlar. Also da haben wir uns immer irgendwas Neues ausgedacht für jeden Wettbewerb, um das Flugzeug irgendwie ein bisschen anders zu machen. Wir hatten einmal eine Kamera, die konnte um zwei Achsen gesteuert werden. Da konnten wir den Terroristen in seinem roten T-Shirt dauernd verfolgen. Das hatte damals sonst keiner. Und so haben wir uns immer ein anderes Flugzeug überlegt, mit dem wir teilgenommen haben.
Der Terrorist im roten T-Shirt, laufen die alle mit dem roten T-Shirt drum. Das Bedrohungsszenario.
Das war so das Bild, das die vermittelt haben.
Okay, also das war dann sozusagen die Hilfe, dass man da eben auch visuell etwas leicht in den Visier nehmen kann.
Ja, also das ist auch nicht so, wie man das aus dem Fernsehen kennt, dass man da so hochfeine Bilder hat, die sich kaum bewegen, wo man, sondern das hat halt geschüttelt und gerüttelt und man konnte dann froh sein, irgendwo so einen roten Blob zu sehen oder so. Also das war nicht die Qualität, die man so aus dem militärischen gewohnt ist, wo dann so Wärmebildkameras oder irgendwie so was mit hochfeinen Mechaniken dann ganz tolle Bilder liefern können.
Und hat sich das jetzt so eingependelt auf so ein bestimmtes Bauprinzip oder wird immer noch breit alles Mögliche erforscht? Oder hat sich jetzt irgendwas herausgebildet als das Optimum?
Das hat sich so, also es geht schon zu Quadcoptern. Oder die Aufgabe hat sich so ein bisschen verschoben. Während das 2005 ging es, oder 2003, 2004 ging es darum überhaupt autonom zu fliegen. Dann ging es darum, das Ganze noch kleiner zu machen und länger zu fliegen und zu optimieren. Und irgendwo so bei diesen 30 Zentimetern Spannweite hat man dann aber einen Punkt erreicht, wo das nicht mehr viel Sinn macht, das noch kleiner zu machen. Und man ist jetzt so bei den Wettbewerben dabei, dass man versucht, die Aufgaben auch automatisch ausführen zu lassen. Dass man eben das Bild absucht nach dem roten T-Shirt oder dem blauen T-Shirt und automatisch irgendwelche Entscheidungen trifft. Dass wenn man ganz viele Leute im roten T-Shirt trifft, landet man auf der roten Wiese. Und wenn ganz viele Blaue, dann auf der blauen. Dass man also die Entscheidung nicht nur das Fliegen, sondern auch die Entscheidung dem Computer noch gibt. Oder dass man komplexere Sachen macht, dass man einen Ballon trifft im Flug oder durch ein Tor fliegt und solche Sachen.
Das sind eigentlich immer solche meditärischen Vorgaben da. Das klingt echt bedrohlich.
Naja, irgendwas muss das Flugzeug ja machen.
Naja, also es kann ja auch was weiß ich, ein Looping fliegen oder so.
Ja.
Man muss ja nicht die ganze Zeit jemand rauspicken und abschießen.
Schießt man da auch? Ja, man hat Mikrofone abgeworfen. Mikrofone? Mikrofone.
Ah, mehr so Abhörsysteme.
Das war glaube ich beim letzten Wettbewerb in Holland, da musste man ein Mikrofon abwerfen.
Was? Na gut, bleiben wir nochmal ein bisschen bei der technischen Begeisterung, bevor wir uns vielleicht auch nochmal dieser philosophischen Fragestellung widmen. Du sagtest, jetzt gerade der Trend geht zu Quadcoptern. Warum? Zählen jetzt die Vorteile der Flächenflugzeuge auf einmal nicht mehr? Oder gibt es Nachteile?
Der Nachteil vom Flächenflugzeug ist, dass du es schlecht beobachten kannst. Du bewegst dich ständig, und der Terrorist bewegt sich ja nicht mit dir, sondern du willst ihn ja beobachten. Und mit dem Quadcopter fliegst du einfach drüber, guckst drauf, fertig. Das ist wesentlich einfacher. Du kannst Quadcopter inzwischen fertig kaufen, Mikrokopter zum Beispiel, oder wenigstens selber die Bauteile kaufen, die wir zusammenbauen. Und du kannst, das ist sicher der riesengroße Vorteil von einem Quadcopter, dass du den vielleicht sogar im Haus, aber mindestens im Garten, im Park, einfach so fliegen kannst. Für ein Flächenflugzeug, ein Flächenflugzeug will ständig in Bewegung sein. Da brauchst du wenigstens eine Wiese, eher einen Modellflugplatz. Und du brauchst auch jemanden, der so ein Flugzeug an sich erst mal fliegen kann. Weil das das erste, was ein Autopilot macht, ist, dass er nicht funktioniert. Und dann bist du froh, wenn du jemanden neben dir hast, der eine Fernsteuerung in der Hand hat, der das Flugzeug erst mal fliegt. Und das ist mit dem Quadcopter wesentlich einfacher. So ein Quadcopter, der hebt ab. Und die Sensorik ist erst mal darauf bedacht, ihn einfach da stehen zu lassen. Und dann fliegst du irgendwo hin und wieder zurück. Und du hast es aber alles sehr einfach unter Kontrolle. Das ist so Videospiel-mäßig, links, rechts, oben, unten. Und nicht so klassisch flugzeugtechnisch ziehen, links, rechts stabilisieren, zur Landung reinkommen, abschätzen, wie hoch, wie schnell, wie weit. Das ist wesentlich einfacher. Deswegen ist es auch für die Leute, die jetzt sich um diese Themen kümmern, oder diese IMAF-Wettbewerbe kümmern, die machen halt Bilderkennung. Das sind nicht unbedingt Piloten. Und für diese ist es dann wesentlich einfacher, das mit Quadcoptern zu machen, als mit einem Flächenflugzeug.
Trotzdem hast du jetzt viel Zeit und Energie in die Flächenflugzeuge investiert. Was erfordert es denn, um nun wirklich ein Flugzeug mehr oder weniger autonom fliegen zu lassen? Also vielleicht mal auch mir als Unwissenden, wenn man jetzt ein normales Modellflugzeug hat, was steuert man mit der Fernbedienung normalerweise?
Du hast einmal den Motor, den du in der Drehzahl verändern kannst. Das hast du auf einem Knüppel. Dann hast du so etwas wie einen Höhenruder bei einem klassischen Flugzeug, wo du, wenn du ziehst, wie im richtigen Flugzeug, geht das Flugzeug hoch. Wenn du drückst, geht es runter. Und dann hast du einen Seitenruder oder eher einen Querruder, also so kleine Flächen in der Tragfläche, die du gegenläufig verstellst, wo du das Flugzeug dann auf die Seite legen kannst und dann eine Kurve fliegst. Also einmal rollen und pitch, roll and pitch, sind so die beiden Hauptachsen, die du irgendwie kontrollieren musst. Und um die zu stabilisieren, haben wir bei den Flächenflugzeugen zunächst Infrarot-Sensoren verwendet. Das sind eigentlich Temperaturmesser, so in ihr Thermometer zum Beispiel, wo ein Seliziumübergang drin ist, der, wenn er mit Wärme bestrahlt wird, eine Spannung entsteht, Thermospannung. Und davon haben wir sechs Stück genommen, haben die in alle Himmelsrichtungen zeigen lassen. Und da der Boden in dem Infrarotbereich wesentlich wärmer ist als der Himmel, kannst du darüber dann den Horizont dir bestimmen.
Okay, vielleicht nochmal kurz zu... Also das eigentliche Problem beim Steuern eines Flugzeuges ist, man darf es natürlich jetzt nicht übermäßig kippen, weil dann verliert es irgendwann seinen Auftrieb und dann ist es auch nicht mehr kontrollierbar.
Genau, das soll schön geradeaus fliegen erst mal als Erstfall.
Genau, es soll gerade mal nicht geradeaus fliegen und eine Kurve machen, aber dann darf man auch nicht zu viel machen. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu fühlen, ist hinzugucken, wenn man jetzt eine Fernbedienung in der Hand hat. Weil es gibt ja in dem Sinne keinen Force-Feedback-Joystick, der einem jetzt irgendwie dasselbe Gefühl geben würde, als wäre man jetzt wirklich der Pilot.
Genau, das ist auch vielleicht das, was das Modellfliegen schwieriger macht als das richtige Fliegen. Im richtigen Flugzeug sitzt du drin und spürst das alles und von unten ist es eine sehr optische Sache. Und gerade wenn du es nicht kannst, hast du die Tendenz, von dir wegzufliegen und dann hast du nur noch so einen Punkt und weißt nicht, wie es in der Luft liegt. Und das Entscheidende ist, diesen optischen Eindruck umzusetzen in die Steuerimpulse, um das Flugzeug geradeaus zu fliegen zu lassen oder eine Kurve zu mir zurückzukommen, solche Sachen.
Das ist ja nicht nur Optik, es ist ja auch Gleichgewichtssinn, der da eine Rolle spielen würde.
Wenn du drin sitzt.
Ja, wenn man drin sitzt, genau. Also klar, als Fernbediener habe ich das jetzt nicht, aber wenn man sich jetzt quasi denkt, ok, jetzt soll das Ding sich selber fliegen, dann muss man ja eigentlich genau diese Sinne nachbilden. Darum geht es. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich nur wissen, wie liege ich gerade. Kann man das so sagen? Das heißt, die eigene Position relativ zur Erdanziehung.
Genau, zur Oberfläche zur Erdanziehung.
Die dann in der Regel halt identisch ist mit Horizontausrichtungen.
Genau, wenn du jetzt an einem Tal fliegst oder an einem Tal, an einem Berg entlang, dann mag das Optische und das Reale nicht ganz übereinstimmen. Aber ansonsten, genau, guckst du dir dein Erdvektor an, deine Erdbeschleunigung und versuchst, wenn du geradeaus fliegst, einfach senkrecht dazu zu fliegen.
Und der erste Ansatz war jetzt Infrarot-Sensorik.
Genau, das war...
Das funktioniert aber dann im Berg nicht so gut.
Möchte man denken, aber das ist kein großer Faktor. Wir sind auch in den Alpen geflogen und man kann jetzt nicht in New York durch die Skyline durchfliegen zwischen den Hochhäusern. Da funktioniert das dann nicht mehr. Da gibt es dann nur noch so einen Streifen Himmel. Aber wenn man jetzt nicht direkt am Berg lang fliegt, dann ist das eigentlich kein großes Problem. Also wir sind auch in den Alpen in Wettbewerbe geflogen und das hat prima funktioniert.
Sechs Stück hast du gesagt?
Genau, sechs Stück.
Das heißt sechs Sensoren, die in alle möglichen Richtungen gucken. Nach unten, nach oben, vorne, hinten links, rechts sozusagen.
Genau. Die waren dann immer, die waren 45 Grad versetzt angebaut. Also nicht nach vorne, hinten, links, rechts, sondern 45 Grad rausgedreht. Schräg vorne, rechts, schräg vorne, links, schräg hinten, links, hinten, rechts. Damit man nicht dauernd auf der Tragfläche oder auf dem Rumpf entlang guckt, sondern in diese Lücke des Flugzeugs.
Und das heißt, dass dann Elektronik da läuft, die diese Sensoren ausliest und dann quasi aus der Summe dieser Messwerte immer ableitet, wie die Lage gerade ist.
Genau.
Ist das schwierig?
Nö, das ist total einfach. Also du bildest sogar schon in Elektronik die Differenz von den Gegenüberliegenden. Und wenn die Null ist, fliegt das Flugzeug gerade. Und wenn es ein bisschen ausgelenkt wird, dann musst du noch ein bisschen Mathematik betreiben, um jetzt aus den sechs Werten zu errechnen, wie der Winkel gerade ist. Das ändert sich auch, deswegen auch sechs Stück. Deswegen guckst du auch immer nach oben und auch immer nach unten, um diese Änderung rauszurechnen. Wenn es sich bewölkt, dann wird es oben doch ein bisschen wärmer. Oder wenn du über einen kalten See fliegst, plötzlich dann ist das Wasser vielleicht auch kälter als das Land. Das musst du ständig anpassen, um wirklich den Winkel ausrechnen zu können. Aber ansonsten, die Mathematik und die ganze Regelung, die da noch dahinter steckt, das hat so ein 8-Bit-Prozessor, so ähnlich einem Arduino, am Anfang zu 17 Prozent ausgelastet. Der war eher gelangweilt.
Wie häufig pro Sekunde muss man da die Messwerte auswerten, um stabil zu sein?
So 60 Hertz.
60 Mal, okay. Aber ich würde jetzt so denken, wenn ich das jetzt nur auswerte, dann könnte ich halt Pitch und Roll damit quasi steuern, aber damit weiß ich ja noch lange nicht, wie schnell ich fliegen muss.
Genau, das sind die beiden Grundlegendstufen, die erstmal dafür sorgen, dass das Flugzeug gerade fliegt. Pitch und Roll, dass es nicht nach rechts, links wegkippt oder runterfällt.
Aber wenn er jetzt nicht genug Gas geben würde, dann würde der Auftrieb abreißen und dann fällt es auch runter.
Genau, deswegen haben wir keine Möglichkeit, die Geschwindigkeit im Wind oder in der Luft, also True Air Speed, THS, zu messen. Also da hat man normalerweise so ein Pitot-Rohr vorne drin. Und das hat man ja auch in den Nachrichten.
Also so ein kleines Rohr nach vorne, wo der Wind, der Fahrtwind direkt rein drückt.
Genau, und das ist ja immer noch kritisch, da fallen immer noch Flugzeuge runter, weil das irgendwie schief geht. Und deswegen haben wir das weggelassen, sondern haben einfach nur die GPS-Geschwindigkeit genommen, die natürlich keinen Hinweis darauf gibt, wie schnell die Luft wirklich über deinen Flügel streicht. Weil wenn du mit dem Wind fliegst, ist diese True Air Speed kleiner. Wenn du gegen den Wind fliegst, dann ist es höher. Deswegen haben wir Flugzeuge, die wir mit einer Mindestgeschwindigkeit fliegen. Also wir gucken uns die GPS-Geschwindigkeit an und haben dann eine Mindestgeschwindigkeit und haben noch eine Regelstufe über die Höhe, die wir entweder über GPS oder kombiniert mit dem Luftdruck messen. Und sobald das Flugzeug halt runtergeht, ziehen wir, dass wir hochgehen und geben auch wieder mehr Gas, um nicht runterzufallen.
Das heißt, in der Konstruktion kommt man jetzt ohne GPS auch nicht aus?
Du kannst das Flugzeug schon fliegen, aber dann nicht koordiniert irgendwo hin. Also es gibt so ein Auto 1, heißt das in Paparazzi, dass du das Flugzeug einfach nur stabilisierst, dass du dafür sorgst, dass du es gerade fliegst. Und du jetzt mit dem Hebel oder mit dem Steuerknüppel nicht mehr die Kontrolloberflächen, die die Control-Software fest ist, bewegst. Sondern du kannst dann damit die Lage des Flugzeugs bestimmen. Und damit fliegt dein Flugzeug wie ein ferngesteuertes Auto. Also wenn du volle Kanne rechts gibst, dann würde ein normales Flugzeug abschmieren und runterfallen. Und dieses Flugzeug fliegt einfach eine Kurve, solange wie du rechts gibst. Und wenn du es loslässt, fliegt es wieder gerade. Und damit kann jeder Mensch sofort ein Modellflugzeug fliegen.
Verstehe. Also das Ganze ist eine intelligente Fernsteuerung, die quasi den Wunsch des Bedieners interpretiert und in die entsprechende Ansteuerungsmechanik umsetzt.
Das ist im Prinzip so, wie man Quadcopter fliegt. Den fliegt man ja auch links, rechts. Da muss man sich ja auch um keine aerodynamik kümmern.
Genau, weil er einfach nochmal so eine Zwischenstufe ist. Und dann die Geschwindigkeit aber auch noch.
Die Geschwindigkeit, die kann man auch bestimmen, einfach indem man Gas gibt in dem Fall. Das ist also was dann links, rechts, schneller, langsam. Und das ist dann wie ein ferngesteuertes Auto.
Und das war sozusagen der erste Design-Ansatz jetzt zum Halbwegsautonom. Ich meine, Puristen würden jetzt sagen, mit GPS ist es ja nicht autonom, weil es braucht ja Satelliten. Aber es ist zumindest so, dass es einen Weg gibt, wie das Ding komplett nur durch Sensorik, auch wenn der Einfluss eben in dem Moment auch Satelliten sind, feststellen kann, wo bin ich, wie bin ich, wie schnell bin ich, oder wie schnell bin ich mindestens, so dass man eben nicht abstürzt.
Also du kannst das Flugzeug ohne Rücksicht auf Aerodynamik oder solche grundsätzlichen flugtechnischen Sachen, die du sonst haben müsstest, erst mal fliegen. Auch ohne GPS.
Und wenn da jetzt so eine kräftige Windböe von der Seite kommt?
Dann dreht er sich wieder hin.
Dann reicht eben 60 Mal pro Sekunde, um da schnell drauf zu reagieren. Das wird ja auch seine Grenzen haben, oder?
Das ist immer so im Sturm des Braus und das tut ihm ein. Das heftigste, was wir mal gemacht haben, war, für Versuche sind wir hinter Windrädern geflogen. Und da hat man an den Flügelspitzen der Windräder einen ganz fürchterlichen Vortex, wo sich das dann ablöst und hat dann einen riesen Wirbel. Und wenn man da genau reinfliegt, dann dreht es das Flugzeug in einer halben Sekunde auf den Kopf und wieder zurück. Also noch bevor der Sicherheitspilot irgendwas sagen konnte, war das Flugzeug schon wieder zurückgedreht. Das war unglaublich schnell. Das ist so das Heftigste, was man sich überlegen kann. Und das meistert er dann auch. Natürlich wird der ungenauer. Je windiger das ist, umso stürmischer es ist, umso unpräziser kann der irgendwie in der Linie folgen. Aber dass man jetzt Probleme hat, passiert ja nicht.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal hier, es gibt ja in den USA diese Tornado-Hunter.
Irgendwo ist dann natürlich Schluss.
Ja, ja, irgendwo ist Schluss. Ich frage mich, wo da Schluss wäre. Hätte man wirklich vielleicht eine Chance, so ein Teil mit Kamera in so ein Tornado reinfliegen zu lassen und er kommt dann auch irgendwie wieder raus?
Nee, also es gibt schon eine Maximalgeschwindigkeit. Wenn der Wind schneller ist als die Grundgeschwindigkeit des Flugzeugs, dann geht da nichts mehr.
Das ist einfach vorbei.
Und das ist so bei den Fliegern, die wir jetzt für die Metrologie einsetzen, ist das so 15 Meter pro Sekunde.
Aber ich meine, wenn er im Tornado drin ist und er wird jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht explizit von irgendetwas Anderem erschlagen, sondern eigentlich nur herumgewirbelt und irgendwann wieder herausgespuckt und er funktioniert noch, dann würde er sich ja sofort wieder stabilisieren und könnte nach Hause fliegen. Oder meinst du, er schafft einfach die Struktur des Flugzeugs nicht mehr?
Irgendwann ist dann mal Schluss. Also dann zerschert es das Flugzeug oder so, ich glaube das.
Dann müsste man dann vielleicht einfach mal ein Gehäuse bauen, was explizit auf solche Kräfte ausgelegt ist. Kohle, Faser, verbunden, Schnickschnack und so. Da gibt es auch allerlei Zeug, oder? Ich träume ein bisschen schon. Okay, aber das war jetzt nur der erste Ansatz.
Das war so der erste Schritt, dass man das Flugzeug erst mal stabilisiert.
Das war jetzt 2002, 2003? Das haben Antoine und Pascal gemacht. Genau. Und da waren sie irgendwie noch allein auf weiter Flur?
Da waren sie allein auf weiter Flur.
Das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du zu denen gestoßen bist, hatten sie schon etwas, was funktionierte?
Genau.
Und das funktionierte auf dieser Basis?
Auf der Infrarot-Basis, genau. Also da konnte man einen Flugplan angeben. Das ist eine eigene Programmiersprache, wo du sagen kannst, fliegt zu dem Punkt oder fliegt ein Kreis oder fliegt ein Bereich ab oder so, ein XML.
Also das heißt, er hätte das GPS nicht nur benutzt, um seine Geschwindigkeit zu kontrollieren, sondern natürlich auch um zu wissen, wo bin ich und wo soll ich hin?
Genau, das ist dann die nächste Stufe, dass du nicht nur das Flugzeug stabilisierst, sondern ihm einen Auftrag gibst, flieg mal dahin. Und dann guckt er, wie stehe ich dazu? Dann muss ich mich mal so drehen, dass ich auf den Punkt zufliege. Und in welcher Höhe soll ich zu dem Punkt? Dann muss ich höher oder tiefer. Und dann fliege ich zu dem Punkt hin. Und dann überlege ich mir den nächsten Punkt. Das war so das einfachste, ist halt zu einem Punkt hinzufliegen. Das schöne bei Paparazzi ist, dass du die Flugsprache, dass du in der Flugsprache auch komplett zäh umsetzen kannst. Das heißt, du kannst Schleife machen, du kannst auf alle Variablen zugreifen. Du kannst dir die abenteuerlichsten Flugfiguren zusammen programmieren. Du bist nicht darauf beschränkt, dass du jetzt nur zu punkten, nur zu strecken oder auf Kreisen fliegen kannst, sondern du kannst dir die Software selber so zusammenbauen. Und das nutzen auch zum Beispiel Metrologen, um außergewöhnliche Effekte zu messen. Die fliegen dann erst mal irgendwo hin, wo Luft durch einen Zwei-Teller oder durch einen Tal durchfließt, zwischen zwei Bergen. Fliegen da Kreise, um den Wind zu bestimmen und wieder zurück.
Um den Wind zu bestimmen, das heißt in dem Moment wird das GPS gar nicht so sehr als Korrektiv, sondern mehr als Messgerät benutzt. Das heißt, man fliegt mit einer konstanten Geschwindigkeit da rein und wird automatisch schneller und langsamer und kann das dann anhand des GPS-Signals messen, wie sehr man quasi mitgeflogen ist mit dem Wind.
Genau, du fliegst mit einer konstanten Leistung.
Genau, das meine ich, genau.
Du nimmst an, dass du die gleiche Geschwindigkeit in der Luft hast und kannst dann auch ohne Pitoro die Windrichtung und die Windgeschwindigkeit relativ präzise bestimmen. Das war dann auch so wichtig für so Sachen, wie wenn man da irgendwie das Mikrofon dann abgeworfen hat, dass man vorher geguckt hat, wo kommt der Wind her? Und dass man dann iterativ ausgerechnet hat, in welche Richtung muss ich anfliegen, wann muss ich das Mikrofon abwerfen, um dann irgendwie so ein Kreuz zu treffen oder so.
Das heißt, in der Stelle sind dann die Sensoren gar nicht mal nur so zum Selbstzweck des Fliegens, sondern das Flugzeug kann auch richtig als Messgerät für in dem Fall meteorologische Anwendungen genutzt werden.
Genau, da ist das ganze Flugzeug im Prinzip das Messgerät, um den Wind zu bestimmen.
Das heißt, man muss noch nicht mal was dranbauen, wenn man das normalerweise denken würde, sondern das fällt einfach dabei ab.
Wir haben dann auch noch einen Drucksensor für die Metrologen, Feuchtigkeitssensoren, Temperatursensoren an Bord. Das ist so die einfachste Ausführung, dass sie so das machen können, was du mit einem Wetterballon machen kannst.
Das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt hat eigentlich das Projekt schon längst seine Spaßphase, also seine nur Spaßphase verlassen. Also es gab auch eine konkrete Anwendung. Warst du da schon dabei, als diese Experimente gemacht wurden? Seid ihr dann auf diese Metrologen zugegangen? Oder wie hat sich das ergeben?
Es gab schon vorher Projekte von den Universitäten, wo man Sachen gemacht hat. Und diese metrologische Anwendung konkret, das war 2006. Da kam Jochen Reuter von der Uni in Bergen aus Norwegen auf uns zu. Der sah uns in Braunschweig bei der Konferenz fliegen und meinte, da müssten wir mal was machen. Der hat schon vorher Modellflugzeuge eingesetzt, um metrologische Messungen zu machen. In dem er mit Ferngläsern vor Brillen das geflogen hat. Da lagen Leute auf Liegen und haben in 3000 Meter Höhe fast nichts mehr zu erkennen. Das haben die Modellflugzeuge gesteuert und haben da gemessen. Und das ist sehr, sehr anstrengend und hat aber prima funktioniert. Die waren in Anden und im Himalaja unterwegs und haben geflogen. Und das war für ihn so die Anwendung, das mit dem Autopiloten zu machen. Das ist wesentlich weniger Stress.
Wie hoch kann denn so ein Paparazzi-Teil fliegen?
Also das Höchste, was wir mal gemacht haben, waren 4.000, 4.500 Meter hoch. Dann war so der Akku leer. Da haben wir es aber gar nicht so drauf angelegt, hoch zu fliegen. Das heißt, man könnte sicherlich noch viel höher. Das Problem ist aber, das erlaubt zu bekommen. Oder überhaupt das Problem bei ungemänten Flugzeugen ist, Dinge erlaubt zu bekommen. Und selbst wenn wir das gemacht haben, dann hat man für uns den Luftraum da entsprechend gesperrt. Da durfte dann kein anderer. Da haben wir dann, also vielleicht von der Reihenfolge 2006 waren so die Gespräche, 2007 sind wir dann in Island mal zu einer Messkampagne dazugestoßen, einfach noch mit hingeflogen, haben ein paar Flugzeuge mitgenommen. Auf Island sind die Wege auch kurz. Da kannte jemand, jemand, der in der Schule war, mit jemandem bei der Flugsicherung. Da haben wir dann morgens mit einem Satellitentelefon angerufen. Und da gab es so ein Notarm, Notice to Airman, dass der Luftraum gesperrt war. Und dann sah man da auch weder kleine Flugzeuge noch Kondensstreifen, irgendwas. Da konnten wir dann erst mal fliegen. Und da sind wir dann mal bis bis 4000 irgendwie hochgeflogen. Und das ist dann schon...
Das war ganz schön kalt.
Ehh, auch gar nicht so. Also bei 4000 Meter wird es noch nicht so richtig kalt. Nee, also Kälte hatten wir dann ein Jahr später auf Spitzbergen. Da waren es dann so minus 20, minus 30. Aber im Sommer auf Island in 4000 Metern vielleicht war es gar nicht mal unter Null.
Was steckt da jetzt konkret an Elektronik drin? Ich meine, das muss ja dann auch schon eine gewisse Temperatur abkönnen.
Der Trick ist, dass wir das mit einem Styropor-Flugzeug machen. Das ist rundum dicht. Die Elektronik heizt sich ja so ein bisschen. Das wirklich Kritische ist der Akku. Das ist so ein Lithium-Polymer-Akku, den du so auch mit dem Handy hast. Der mag es nicht, wenn ihm schon Kälte als 15 Grad plus wird. Dann gibt er schon wenige Leistung ab und findet das nicht mehr gut. Da kam uns entgegen, dass es jetzt sehr viele Styropor-Flugzeuge gibt. Da haben wir auch ein Standard-Modellflugzeug genommen. Wir haben das noch verstärkt und die Sensoren reingebaut. Das ist temperaturmäßig eigentlich kein großes Problem.
Das heißt, der Styropor isoliert einfach super, weil es Luft einschließt und das einfach der beste Isolator überhaupt ist?
Genau. Da wird alles zugemacht, alles dicht. Da gibt es normalerweise Kühlöffnungen, dass der Akku gekühlt wird. Wenn du das so bei 25 Grad im Sommer fliegen lassen möchtest, das wird alles zugemacht und dann funktioniert das wunderprima. Also wir haben auch mal versucht, die vorzuheizen, um noch mehr Energie rauszuholen, aber das macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied. Und die Elektronik ist in so einem Schrumpfschlauch eingeschrumpft, die heizt sich selber. Und selbst hinten im Laderaum, wo dann...
Die gesamte Elektronik ist in so einem Schlumpfer, also es kommt...
Ne, verschiedene Komponenten sind so eingeschrumpft.
Aber die sind dann auch entsprechend wasserdicht. Und es ist wahrscheinlich eh schon in dem Styropor.
Ja, also man kann auch bei heftigem Regen nicht fliegen. Aber wenn es so ein bisschen trottfüllt, dann macht das auch nichts. Und selbst, obwohl das nach hinten dann offen ist, weil der Motor da sitzt und der schon so ein bisschen Luftkühlung braucht, wurde es dann nie kälter als 10 Grad nach hinten raus, wo der eigentliche Autopilot sitzt. Also der Autopilot hat einen GPS, der hat so ein Netzteil, der hat den eigentlichen Computer. Dann entweder das Infrarot oder das Inertialsystem, was dann nach dem Infrarot kam, dann noch ein paar Sensoren hinten mit drin und vorne der Akku und fertig.
Und was ist das für eine Elektronik?
Das ist Paparazzi. Also die Paparazzis haben von Anfang an die Hardware selber entwickelt. Und das ist so checkkartengroß. Es gibt inzwischen verschiedene Ausführungen, aber so die erste Version, die wir gebaut haben, die damals noch im Hinblick auf die Wettbewerbe war, dass es also möglichst klein und kompakt wird. Da sitzt der GPS-Empfänger und die GPS-Antenne auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite sitzt der Computer. Und die ganzen Anschlüsse, wo man die Servos und den Motor und die Sensoren anschließt, von unten noch ein kleines Schaltnetzteil, was das alles mit Strom versorgt. Und damit kannst du das eigentlich schon fliegen. Und dann sitzen noch ein paar Sensoren daneben, eine USB-Buchse, um das Ding zu flaschen. Der Akku sitzt dann vorne in einem eigenen Compartment, das noch ein bisschen dichter ist als hinten das. Und aus dem Prozessor? Am Anfang war es eben so was Arduino-ähnliches, so ein ATmega-8-Bit-Prozessor. Und jetzt ist es ein ARM 7 seit 2006 und der neue ist dann ein Cortex-M3 von ST Also auch ARM-Architektur.
Genau.
Und der hat viel mehr Rechenpower, als wir jemals brauchen. Es gibt auch noch...
Also fürs Fliegen brauchen.
Fürs Fliegen brauchen. Es gibt auch noch ein Board, wo man so einen GAM-Sticks dranstecken kann. Also so einen richtigen Linux-Rechner mit 600 MHz oder so. Wenn man richtig mal oder ein bisschen mehr rechnen möchte. So wirklich Bilderkennung kann man dann auch nicht damit machen. Aber da gibt es auch Leute, die dann über Kameras Bilderkennung machen und dann mit grafischen oder mit optischen Mitteln des Flugzeugs stabilisieren, statt das mit GPS zu machen.
Also den optischen Fluss quasi auswerten an der Stelle.
Genau.
Das wäre ja auch eine Methode, um die wirkliche Geschwindigkeit über Grund auch zu messen. Aber das hat man auch mit GPS, oder?
Ja, da hast du ja wieder über Grund. Du willst ja in der Luft. Also da gibt es lustige...
Ist das ein ungelöstes Problem noch?
Also die klassische Methode ist ein Pitouro. Das haben wir auch jetzt in den metrologischen Fliegern mit drin, so ein Pitouro, um die Windgeschwindigkeit oder die Luftgeschwindigkeit zu messen. Aber das ist nicht sehr zuverlässig, weil das auch... Das geht quadratisch und dann bei so kleinen Geschwindigkeiten, also klein im Verhältnis zu einem Jetflugzeug, ist das nicht sehr präzise. Es gibt noch andere Methoden, dass man zum Beispiel ein Draht heizt mit einer bestimmten Energie und sich guckt, und sich anguckt, wie sehr wird er abgekühlt durch den Luftstrom. Oder es gibt jetzt auch mikromechanische Sensoren, wo du quasi mit einem Mikrofon dir anschaust, was da an Luftmenge drüber geht.
Mit einem Mikrofon sozusagen?
Also mit einem Silizium-Mikrofon, mit einem mikromechanischen kleinen Mikrofon. Das haben wir aber noch nicht. Das habe ich nur auf Folien bisher gesehen. Aber da gibt es auch interessante Sachen.
So, also wir haben halt so ein Styropor-Flugzeug. Das ist in der Lage, sich selber zu steuern. Das ist in der Lage, überall hinzufliegen. Das ist in der Lage, mit seinen benötigten Sensoren bereits Messungen zu machen über Windgeschwindigkeiten. Weil man da die Differenz bilden kann, zu der realen Bewegung über Grund, indem man eben GPS auswertet. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von sonstigen Sensoren, die man jetzt zum Beispiel für die Meteorologie benutzen kann. Du hast jetzt vorhin noch so ein Inertialsystem erwähnt, das dann dazugekommen sei.
Was ist das? Das ist so der Sensor, den du auch im Handy drin hast.
Also ein Beschleunigungssensor?
Ein Beschleunigungssensor und ein Drehratensensor. Also eins alleine reicht nicht, sondern du brauchst immer auch noch die Drehrate dafür.
Also ein Gyroskop?
Genau, drei Achsen jeweils, eine Beschleunigung und dann das Gyroskop. Das ist das, was man beim Quadcopter von Anfang an eingesetzt hat, weil da die Infrarot-Technik nicht präzise genug und vor allen Dingen auch nicht schnell genug ist, bis sich dieses Stückchen Silizium entsprechend aufgeheizt hat. Vergehen 20 Millisekunden, 30 Millisekunden, das hat da nie so richtig funktioniert. Deswegen hat man da Gyroskope und Beschleunigungssensoren eingesetzt. Und die sind inzwischen so gut und die Algorithmen so zuverlässig, dass man das auch problemlos im Flächenflugzeug verwenden kann. Das war am Anfang ein bisschen schwieriger. Wie gesagt, so ein Quadcopter möchte erstmal stehen bleiben. Da kann man einfach dafür sorgen, dass er sich nicht dreht und nicht bewegt und dass der Beschleunigungssensor so ein G anzeigt quasi. Ein Flugzeug bewegt sich ja von sich aus ständig. Da war das ein bisschen schwieriger. Wenn du ein Flugzeug fliegt auch hauptsächlich Kurven, dass du beim Flugzeug irgendwo bist, um dich kreist, fliegst du halt auch dauernd Kurven. Und da hast du ja durch die Beschleunigung, die du bekommst, dass du im Kreis fliegst, auch schon nochmal eine Beschleunigung, die auf die Erdbeschleunigung oben drauf kommt. Und deswegen musst du diese beiden Sensoren eben noch mathematisch zusammenbringen, um da wirklich zu wissen, wie du liegst. Also es reicht nicht nur einfach, einen Beschleunigungs-Sensor zu nehmen, sondern du musst Beschleunigungs-Sensor, Drehratensensor und dann als langfristige Nullung, quasi hast du noch das GPS. Die drei Sachen musst du zusammenbringen, um wirklich ein Flächenflugzeug fliegen zu können.
Welchen Vorteil hat das dann geboten gegenüber der bewährten Methode, die ja schon ganz gut funktioniert hat?
Die Infrarot-Sensoren funktionieren nur, wenn du die Erde auch siehst. Das heißt, du kannst nicht in Wolken fliegen und du kannst nicht bei Nebel fliegen oder im Schneesturm, was wir da auch hatten. Das heißt, du hast so wie in einer normalen Fliegerei so Sichtflug. Das heißt, du musst jetzt den Horizont nicht wirklich sehen. Das ist ein bisschen unkritischer als die reine Sicht. Aber irgendwo gibt es zwei Begrenzungen. Der Vorteil war und ist weiterhin, dass es dann sehr zuverlässig funktioniert gegenüber allen Beschleunigungs- und Drehradensensoren. Aber es gab halt Einschränkungen. Es gab, wenn wir auf Island waren oder auf Spitzbergen waren oder auf einem Eisbrecher unterwegs waren, gab es auch immer Tage, an denen wir einfach nicht fliegen konnten, weil die Suppe bis unten stand und dann ging halt nichts. Und mit den neuen Sensoren fällt es halt flach. Da kannst du auch fliegen. Da könntest du auch im Nebel oder in den Wolken fliegen. Dann musst du es aber auch wieder dürfen. Also wenn du keinen gesperrten Luftraum hast, dann darfst du auch nicht fliegen, ohne dass du das Flugzeug siehst oder andere Flugzeuge.
Zumindest nicht in einer bestimmten Höhe.
Du musst schon den ganzen Luftraum um das Flugzeug beobachten können.
Was ja auch noch ein Problem ist, ist die Messung der Höhe. Also bedient ihr euch da dann auch einfach das GPS? Aber reicht das auch aus für so kritische Momente wie Landung?
Ja.
Landet das Ding denn so richtig schön selbst? Also wirft es sich selbst ab und hofft, gefangen zu werden.
Also du kannst nicht auf dem Handtuch landen. Du brauchst schon ein bisschen mehr Platz. Aber ansonsten funktioniert das. Also die GPS-Höhe ist schon…
Das Flugzeug hat auch Räder?
Nö, das landet auf dem Bauch. Okay. Also das landet auch nicht auf einer Piste, sondern dann im Schnee oder auf Island irgendwo in den Steinfeldern.
Das ist stabil genug, dass das sowas auch immer aushält?
Genau. Da sind von unten ist nochmal Glasfaser drunter und Kohleverstärkung…
Unter dem Styropor.
Unter dem Styropor. Also das reine Styropor, das haben wir am Anfang gehabt, das kann so den isländischen Steinen und Treulen nicht so wirklich beisetzen.
Aber das heißt, Höhenmessung in GPS ist ja sehr träge, oder? Es ist eher unpräzise. Ungenau.
Ungenau. Weil du hast die Satelliten eher um dich herum. Und deswegen ist das System nicht so dafür gebaut, die Höhe wirklich präzise zu messen. Du hast ja auch von unten keine, du hast ja nur die Halbkugel.
Wie groß ist so die Ungenauigkeit da?
Wahrscheinlich so um die zehn Meter.
Das heißt, das Ding weiß eigentlich nicht, ob es zehn Meter über Grund ist oder schon am Boden.
Aber zehn Meter ist nicht so kritisch, wenn du genug Platz hast. Dann kommst du einfach bis auf die letzten 20 Meter runter. Und dann wirst du ganz langsam und fällst auch ganz langsam und wartest einfach, dass der Boden dann da ist. Das funktioniert halt nicht, wenn du auf dem Handtuch landen möchtest. Aber wenn du so eine große Eis- oder Schneefläche hast oder eine große Wiese, dann passt das schon.
Das heißt, das Ding hat einfach Vertrauen. Also, die Erde kann jetzt nicht mehr so weit weg sein, macht irgendwie die Augen zu und streckt den Bauch raus und plumpst.
Genau. Oder wenn es halt überhaupt nicht passt, dann drückst du halt auf den Knopf und dann versucht das nochmal und dann sagst du hier, mach mal 10 Meter Höhe oder mach mal 10 Meter Tiefe. Und dann landet er halt dann.
Wenn man das Gefühl hat, dass es jetzt ein bisschen bekloppt ist und ja, bitte landen, aber nicht genau da. Dann gibt es so einen Durchstart, einen Durchstart, einen Knopf.
Genau.
Also in dem Moment hat man schon auch noch eine Fernbedienung in dem Sinne.
Jederzeit. Also du hast immer jemanden hoffentlich neben dir stehen. Also du hast einen, der den Rechner bedient, wo du sagst, so jetzt fliegen wir mal hier hin, jetzt fliegen wir mal hoch und mal weit und irgendwas. Und daneben steht immer jemand, der eine ganz klassische Fernsteuerung hat, der auch ein guter Modellbau-Pilot ist. Und der hat letztlich den Schalter in der Hand. Und der ist irgendwie auch der letztlich verantwortliche Flugzeugführer. Und wenn der sagt, das gefällt mir nicht, dann macht es klack. Und dann hat er den ganz normal und fliegt den von Hand.
Aber er steuert ihn so wie ein Quadrocopter, also mit diesem, was du vorhin erklärt hast, mit dieser einfachen Steuerung und jetzt nicht, indem er wirklich hier das einzelne Motorgelenk selber noch anspricht.
Ja, wenn er weiter weg ist, fliegt er den wie ein Quadcopter. Wenn er näher dran ist oder wenn irgendwas kritisches passiert, dann kann er so in so einen Raw-Modus schalten. Genau, dann kann er das Link fliegen, so wie er das geht.
Ah ja, okay, verstehe.
Das ist so letztlich auch die Auflage, wenn man sowas genehmigt bekommt, dass du ständig jemanden hast, der den Luftraum beobachtet und guckt, ob da nicht vielleicht auch ein Rettungshubschrauber vorbeifliegt oder ein Segelflieger hier landen möchte oder irgendwie sowas. Und wenn du auf den Laptop guckst, kannst du auch schwerlings alles um dich herum beobachten. Allein das Fokussieren nahe fern, das ist relativ schwierig. Und deswegen brauchst du immer jemanden. Also es funktioniert nicht, dass du ein Laptop hast und das Flugzeug mit Laptop und mit Computer und alles zusammen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht genau, wie die sportliche Veranlagung so ist. Ich meine, wenn man sich so kreativ mit Techniker auseinandersetzt und schon merkt, jetzt können wir das, jetzt können wir das, jetzt können wir das, dann will man ja dann immer noch den nächsten Schritt gehen. Bei dem, was du jetzt bisher geschildert hast, ist klar, er kann weit fliegen, weiß immer, wo er ist, kann alles Mögliche messen, kann irgendwie sich... Landen willst du jetzt mal nicht nennen, aber er kann sich irgendwie entspannt fallen lassen. Aber er geht ja eigentlich immer davon aus, dass auch Platz fehlen ist. Und wenn jetzt irgendwie so Bäume oder so Berge oder Masten und Kabel und so ein Scheiß, das liegt ja auch rum, kann man da so mit Abstands-Sensoren, mit Ultraschall... Hast du so einen Fledermaus-Modus, wo er dann auch noch durch eine Höhle fliegen könnte, oder ist das irgendwie noch unerreicht?
Eher nicht. Also das ist, glaube ich, eher was auch für Quadcopter, die dann auch ruhig genug sind, um den Raum zu erfassen, mit Laser oder mit Ultraschall oder irgendwas. Wir gehen eigentlich immer davon aus, dass wir genug Platz haben. Weil wir halt sehr hoch oder sehr weit weg fliegen.
Aber bei Star Wars habe ich das ja schon in 70er Jahren gesehen, dass die Viecher da irgendwie durch den Wald fliegen. So in Brusthöhe.
Man muss ja auch noch Ziele haben.
Versuch die gerade abzuklopfen. Ich meine, es ist vorstellbar, es ist denkbar, dass man jetzt auch noch so eine High-Speed-Sensorik reinbaut, wo das Ding ja auch wirklich verdammt schnell reagieren müsste. Und ja auch da, ich war ja nicht unmittelbar, also Quadrocopter, der bleibt dann einfach stehen. Das Flugzeug muss ja weiter fliegen und braucht ja da irgendwie eine Strategie. Muss ja im Prinzip auch weit gucken können, um wirklich für solche Situationen zu planen. Also ich meine allein schon so dieses, keine Ahnung, wie schnell fliegen die Fische normalerweise so?
So 60, 70 Stundenkilometer.
Okay, so das heißt, da müsste man aber auch schon so 10, 20, 30, 40 Meter nach vorne gucken, um einfach noch genug Zeit zu haben, um zum Beispiel hochzuziehen. So sehe ich, der fliegt irgendwie irgendwo rüber und dann kommt ein Berg. Meine Berge stehen ja rum. Die kommen ja recht unerwartet.
Was ist dann?
Dann fliegt er einfach da rein.
Also wir hatten im Sommer eine Messkampagne in Frankreich. Da hatten sich verschiedene Metrologen getroffen, haben Masten aufgebaut. Und der Mast war 60 Meter hoch. Und die optimistischen Metrologen haben dann gesagt, das Flugzeug sollte mal 65 Meter hoch fliegen. Und dann kam die GPS-Ungenauigkeit. Und dann war oben auf dem Masten noch so ein dünner Stab. Und da ist jetzt so eine orange Schmiss dran. Also da ist man dann genau reingeflogen. Und dann ist er halt runtergefallen. Ich glaube, die Forschung ist eher so, dass man bei den Wettbewerben jetzt so durch Tore durchfliegt. Die sind dann irgendwie fünfmal fünf Meter. Und da tastet man sich langsam ran, hat so Bilderkennung und kann da jetzt so durchfliegen. So als Aufgabe. So ganz langsam und mit einem Hubschrauber und so. Das ist, was die DLR in Braunschweig auch zum Beispiel macht. Solche Bilderkennung. Also da geht es sicherlich hin. Es gibt eine Menge Leute, die sich mit Bilderkennung und solchen Sachen beschäftigen. Aber das ist dann eher so ein Spezialproblem. Das hat jetzt so mit dem Fliegen nicht unbedingt was zu tun. Also das ist mir so die Bilderkennung.
Bilderkennung funktioniert natürlich nur mit Licht. Was ist jetzt so in der Höhle oder so? Ich meine, wäre ja super, wenn man so Tropfsteinhöhle... Okay, das ist dann doch wieder, was für die Quadrocopter. Ich merke schon. Okay, also Höhenmessung in dem Sinne und Abstandsmessung ist jetzt noch nicht so richtig das Thema.
Also was wir gemacht haben, war, dass wir versucht haben, zu vermeiden, dass sich die Flugzeuge irgendwie untereinander. Die wissen ja, wo sie sind. Die können auch miteinander reden, sagen, wo bist du? Ich bin hier.
Du kannst so Peer-to-Peer-Funk machen.
Genau. Also die können, ja...
Was liefern die sich? Die liefern sich quasi GPS-Koordinaten.
Genau, Höhe, Geschwindigkeit, Flugrichtung. Und da gab es an der ENAC ein Projekt, das man so ähnlich wie TICAS, dieses System, das es in der Luftfahrt gibt, um sich auszuweichen. Und das hat man einfach auf Paparazzi-Flugzeuge umgesetzt. Die fliegen aufeinander zu, die merken das. Der eine sagt, na, ich geh mal runter. Der andere sagt, ich geh mal hoch. Und dann fliegen die aneinander vorbei. Da gibt es auch ein paar Videos, das hat so ganz gut funktioniert.
Das heißt, ihr habt quasi so programmiert, dass ihr auf denselben Punkt, zum selben Zeitpunkt kommt. Wie macht man das konkret? Sagt man einfach nur fliegt da lang, fliegt da lang, fliegt da lang? Oder kann man auch sagen, sei um diese Uhrzeit da. Und dann gibt er mehr Gas oder so?
Die Geschwindigkeit wirklich zu bestimmen, ist schwierig bei Paparazzi, weil es mit der Höhenregelung zusammenhängt. Dieses, was wir gesagt hatten, wenn wir irgendwie sinken, dann geben wir Gas. Und weil das so eine kombinierte Geschichte ist, aus Geschwindigkeit und Höhenhaltung ist es relativ schwierig, zu einer vorgegebenen Zeit irgendwo zu sein. Das klappt so ungefähr.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht auf die Millisekunde, aber die Tageszeit treffen sozusagen. Weil ich meine, gerade wenn man jetzt Messungen macht, ist es ja dann auch nicht unerheblich, wann das ist. Also wenn man meteorologisch misst, dann will man ja vielleicht auch zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit immer einen bestimmten Messpunkt reinholen. Was haben die Dinger für eine Reichweite? Was kann man da so abfliegen lassen mit so einem Akku?
Also bei den Fliegern, die wir so gebaut haben, ging es eher darum, so ein vertikales Profil zu fliegen. Also die sind jetzt nicht so dafür gedacht, weit rauszufliegen. Das geht vielleicht so 10, 15 Kilometer, sondern es geht darum, möglichst schnell hoch auf 4000 Meter. Meistens jetzt auf Spitzbergen dürfen wir so 1500 Meter hoch. Da gab es die Auflage, dass wenn der Rettungshubschrauber startet, dann hat man den in zwei Minuten aus der Halle rausgezogen und wir mussten in zwei Minuten dann wieder gelandet sein. Und da war 1500 Meter so Schicht. Dann fliegt er hoch auf 1500 Meter, segelt langsam wieder runter, fliegt dann nochmal hoch auf 1500 Meter, weil er den Akku noch hat. Dann geht jemand raus, landet das Flugzeug, wechselt den Akku, geht wieder raus, fliegt wieder hoch, wieder runter, wieder hoch, wieder runter, wechselt wieder. Der Trick dabei ist auch nicht die Präzision, um jetzt genau zu sagen, zu dem Zeitpunkt war ich da, sondern der Trick ist die Datendichte. Also, dass du über 24 Stunden diese Luftsäule an diesem Punkt sehr präzise vermessen kannst. Dass du mit einer Cessna gar nicht so könntest, mit einem Ballon auch nicht, weil der weggepustet wird. Und das ist dann auch das Neue an dieser Messmethode, dass du sehr dicht Daten messen kannst und das eben sehr günstig tun kannst, weil der Doktorand, der kommt dann mal ein paar Tage vorbei, dann biegen wir ihm das bei, wie das so ungefähr funktioniert, und dann fliegt er das Flugzeug selber. Dann kannst du halt sehr günstig sehr dicht Daten zusammensammeln, auch in Gegenden, wo es sehr kalt ist.
Also sehr dicht im Sinne von sehr vielen Messpunkten, weil er eigentlich zu jedem Zeitpunkt schon einen Messwert hat und man so richtig so eine 3D-Wolke an Daten da generiert über die Zeit.
Genau, also einmal lokal, aber auch zeitlich, dass du nicht einmal morgens zum Flug machst und abends zum Flug machst, sondern die ganze Nacht, und dann kriegst du irgendwie so Megabyteweise Daten und kannst dir dann sehr gut angucken, wie zum Beispiel der Wind dreht über den Tag oder wie sich da Sachen entwickeln, die Grenzpflicht steigt hoch, runter, was auch immer.
Aber 15 Kilometer hast du gesagt.
15, mit dem Flieger 15, also wenn man weiter fliegen würde, würde man ein anderes Flugzeug nehmen. Das Flugzeug, wovon ich jetzt spreche, dieser Funjet oder Sumo, wie er in der mythologischen Welt heißt, der ist eher so gedacht, um schnell hochzukommen, auch bei Wind noch hochzukommen und langsam wieder runterzukommen.
Ich hatte vor kurzem im Rahmen meines anderen Podcasts Raumzeit, den ich da mit DLR und ESA mache, die Möglichkeit, einen Parapel-Flug mitzumachen. Wenn ich jetzt so höre, was hier alles an Sensorik drin ist, ist ja sehr schwer zu fliegen. Und die Piloten fliegen das ja von Hand ohne jetzt. Aber wenn ihr sowieso schon mit Beschleunigungssensoren arbeitet, seid ihr euch ja sozusagen des Gs immer sehr bewusst. Habt ihr mal ausprobiert, so einen Parapel-Flug zu fliegen? Man meint es ja, man kann das sehr genau bestimmen, was man da fliegt. Dann wäre es ja auch Möglichkeit, Schwerelosigkeit herzustellen.
Als ich den Podcast gehört habe und dann auch noch gesagt wurde, dass es mit Autopiloten nicht möglich wäre, habe ich gedacht, das müsste ja eigentlich doch möglich sein. Und da so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, es ist ja was ganz anderes, wenn du so einen Parapel-Flug machst, ist das ja mehr so das Flugzeug, was du schmeißt und was dann irgendwie fliegt.
Ja, es fällt dann halt und fliegt nicht mehr so richtig.
Genau, das heißt, all diese Regelungsstufen, die du da so drin hast, die dafür sorgen, dass das Flugzeug eben fliegt und nicht geschmissen wird, müsstest du wahrscheinlich raustun, müsstest irgendwas einbauen, müsstest versuchen, diesen Wurf, also du kannst ja die Beschleunigung sehr gut messen, kannst ja auch dafür sorgen, dass die Beschleunigung immer null ist, indem du halt ziehst oder drückst. Ausprobiert haben wir das noch nicht. Es wäre mal eine spannende Sache, das sich anzugucken, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob und wie man das, man müsste erstmal probieren, ob ein Modellflugpilot das so hinbekommt. Dass man einfach die Gs misst und man sagt, hier, flieg mal hoch.
Versuch mal eine richtige Parabel zu fliegen, und dann gucken wir mal, wie nullig das dann wirklich war.
Genau, das war auch meine Idee. Aber sind wir noch nicht so gekommen, uns das irgendwie mal näher anzuschauen.
Was sind denn so, ich meine, du hast ja jetzt schon so einige Anwendungen erläutert. Da gibt es ja sicherlich noch eine ganze Menge mehr, worüber wir noch gar nicht so viel geredet haben. Es ist natürlich die generelle Möglichkeit, das Ding einfach als fliegendes Auge zu verwenden. Also jetzt mal abgesehen von den Terroristen im roten T-Shirt, könnte man ja auch einfach Erdbeobachtungen im weiteren Sinne betreiben.
Gab es da schon irgendwie praktisch irgendwas? Die erste Sache war irgendwo im Atlantik. In Frankreich gibt es irgendwie so eine große Insel. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie die hieß. Und da hat man beobachtet, wie das Watt sich verändert. Da ist man einfach alle halbe Jahr hin, ist da in so einem Schleifenmuster drüber geflogen, hat da Aufnahmen gemacht, hat die so ganz einfach zusammengestitched mit einer einfachen Software. Und da haben sich dann Meeresbiologen angeschaut, wie verändert sich das Watt. Solche Sachen. Das scheint jetzt so recht interessant zu werden kommerziell. Da gibt es eine Menge kleine Firmen, die sich darum kümmern, so kleine auch Styropor-Flugzeuge mit normalen Kleinbildkameras oder digitalen Kleinkameras auszurüsten. Und dann nicht nur in 2D das zu stitchen, sondern in 3D. Das heißt, du fliegst irgendwo auf einem Kieswerk über so einen Haufen Kies ein paar Mal drüber, machst da verschiedene Aufnahmen. Die Software bildet da so Kugelwolken raus. Und hinterher kannst du sagen, der Kieshaufen hat 5000 Kubikmeter Kies oder so. Also das scheint sich gerade so als Anwendung herauszubilden. Auch irgendwie zur Erfassung von Bodenbeschaffenheit oder so ist das ein großes Ding. Und dann kannst du gerade mit dieser Software zum 3D-Stitchen sehr viel machen. Also da kannst du dir die Bilder drehen, angucken und kriegst damit...
Das heißt, dann ist die Kamera drehbar?
Nee, die Kamera guckt einfach nur nach unten.
Das heißt, das muss jetzt das Flugzeug drehen?
Nee, du fliegst einfach...
Ach so, man guckt immer nur nach unten und baut dann die Dinger zusammen?
Genau, ganz einfach an Kameras.
Und ich dachte dafür, um das effektiv zu machen, wäre es auch nötig, quasi mit 45 Grad oder einem definierten Quer...
Nee, du fliegst möglichst gerade drüber. Und bekommst ja schon daraus, was du siehst. Du guckst ja nicht an jeder Stelle senkrecht runter.
Genau, man guckt ja eigentlich in allen möglichen Winkeln. Das stimmt, gleichzeitig.
Das ist natürlich schwer.
Ich 45, aber halt irgendwelche Winkel.
Genau, das ist natürlich schwer. Wenn du das irgendwie in der Arktis machst, wo alles weiß ist, da kriegst du dann auch nichts raus. Aber wenn du ein sehr texturiertes Gebiet hast, dann bekommst du recht gute 3D-Bilder davon, was da passiert. Das ist eine kommerziell auch interessante Anwendung für die Forschung, Geografie und solche Sachen. Was wir noch gemacht haben, war eben diese Windräder mit der ETH Zürich zusammen. Die haben einen sehr präzisen Siebenlochsensor gebaut, um auch 3D-Windvektoren bestimmen zu können. Also nicht nur der Wind, der von vorne kommt, sondern auch aus den verschiedenen Richtungen. Das haben wir in so ein Flugzeug integriert. Wir haben da Elektronik gebaut, die Messwerte zu erfassen, auf SD-Card wegzuschreiben, aber auch über Paparazzi runterzuschicken. Und da fliegen wir jetzt hinter Windrädern und versuchen eben die Turbulenzen, die so ein Windrad erzeugt, zu messen. Und dann eben auch zu messen, wie sich Windräder gegenseitig beeinflussen und wie du Windräder vielleicht sinnvoller aufstellen kannst oder wo du überhaupt Windräder sinnvoller aufstellen kannst, indem du vorher präziser misst, wie viel Wind ist denn da überhaupt. Also die erste Anwendung war hier in der Nähe in Hameln. Da war ein Windrad, was irgendwie mechanisch Ärger gemacht hat und man wusste nicht, warum. Und da sind wir dann geflogen und haben dann festgestellt, dass die Windverteilung an dem Windrad nicht so ist, wie sie idealerweise ist, sondern dass irgendwie in 110 Meter Höhe plötzlich die Windgeschwindigkeit nochmal stark zunahm, die dann dafür gesorgt hat, dass das Rad mechanisch immer ausgestiegen ist. Und das kannst du halt normalerweise nur mit Masten messen, vielleicht noch ein bisschen mit Lidar, mit Lasern, nicht so präzise und mobil, wie du das halt beim Flugzeug machen kannst.
Also ich meine gerade so diese Erdbeobachtung, ich meine du hast jetzt dieses Beispiel da mit dem Kies und 3D und so weiter gemacht, ich meine man kann das Ding ja vielleicht auch generell einfach, jetzt sind wir auch schon wieder beim Bedrohungsszenario. Ich meine das sind natürlich auch einfach extrem billige Dauerüberwachungsfliegerchen. Die sind ja auch nicht besonders laut, oder?
Nee, das merkst du nicht wirklich, dass der da oben rumfliegt und dich beobachtet.
Der summt da so ein bisschen vor sich hin, aber kann ja irgendwie extrem hochfliegen. Ich meine was ist so eure normale Operatinghöhe, wo man so schöne Bilder von unten machen kann, die halbwegs wo man den Terroristen noch erkennt.
70, 80, 100 Meter ist so die normale Flughöhe.
Aber da hört man nichts von dem Teil.
Ja, das hörst du schon. Bei 70, 80 oder auch 100 Metern siehst du so ein 70 Zentimeter Flugzeug schon.
Aber man hört das jetzt nicht unbedingt so massiv.
Es wird dir wahrscheinlich nicht auffallen. Also wenn du weißt, dass es da ist, dann schon. Aber wenn du nicht weißt, dass das Flugzeug da ist oder so, dann merkt man das wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich.
Was ist denn so, was ich mir so vorstellen kann, du hast ja gesagt, so 10 bis 15 Kilometer. Wie lange bleibt der dann so in der Luft? Was war nochmal die Zeit, du hast es schon mal gesagt? 20 Minuten, 30 Minuten, so die Dinger sind relativ billig zu bauen. Könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass es so in Katastrophensituationen, was weiß ich, Erdbeben, Verschüttete finden. Wäre das nicht da auch eine sinnvolle Anwendung? Ich meine, wenn das Ding mit Infrarot bestückt ist und in der Lage ist, verhältnismäßig niedrig über so ein Gebiet rüber zu fliegen, dass es in der Lage ist, weiß ich nicht, Personen zu finden oder in irgendeiner anderen Form zumindest aufklärerisch zu arbeiten, indem es dann eben einfach mal fixen Mapping macht. Also, weiß ich nicht, wie langsam. Da gibt es ja sicherlich irgendeinen Kompromiss. Man kann irgendwie die Fotos nur in einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit machen. Dann muss es sich ja auch überlappen. Das Ding muss aber eine Mindestgeschwindigkeit haben. Das heißt, es muss auch eine Mindesthöhe haben, damit das irgendwie passt, damit es sich noch wirklich überlappt. Was ist da so der übliche Kompromiss? Muss 100 Meter hoch fliegen, damit das gut funktioniert? Oder muss man jetzt wahrscheinlich mal irgendwie ausrechnen. Aber ich weiß, was ich meine. Ein kontinuierliches Fotografieren von jedem Detail, während es irgendwie eine Gegend überfliegt und dann eben versucht, so zu fliegen, um einfach so schnell wie möglich eine möglichst zusammenhängende, brauchbar scharfe Karte eines Gebietes zu erzeugen.
Ich glaube, das kann man mit Satelliten besser machen. Oder wenn du eine wirkliche Katastrophe hast, dass du ein normales Flugzeug hinfliegst. Ich glaube, der Trick bei den ungemänten kleinen Flugzeugen ist eher, dass du sehr präzise Fotos machen kannst. Dass du eben wirklich bis auf einen Kubikmeter gucken kannst, wie groß ist der Haufen, der da ist.
Ja, aber für Rettungsteams, ich meine, die können jetzt nicht unbedingt noch ein Flugzeug machen. Und die Auflösung, ich meine, man muss ja sehen können, ist das jetzt, also ist das eine Situation, wo offensichtlich ist, dass Hilfe benötigt wird, ja? Oder ist es nur ein zerstörtes Haus? Das kriegt man vom Satelliten nicht gesagt.
Ja, also wenn du jetzt konkret eine Situation hast und das schnell hinbringen kannst, kann das sicherlich sinnvoll sein. Vielleicht ist dann der Flächenflieger wieder besser als der Quadcopter um größere Flächen.
Jaja, das meint jemand. Wir haben jetzt hier gerade wieder Türkei. Alle Nase lang sind da irgendwelche Erdbeben. Das sind riesige Flächen. Man weiß ja auch am Anfang gar nicht, wie weit... Gut, es gibt gute Erdbebemessungen. Man weiß in etwa, wie groß die Dimension ist. Aber schnell eine Karte zu haben, ist einfach für Retter sinnvoll. Auch gerade, wenn man irgendwie eine Vermutung hat, dass es irgendwie sein könnte. Dann sieht man sofort, aha, da stehen noch alle Häuser. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt hin. Aber da, da sieht es richtig bekloppt aus. Da müssen wir jetzt schnell hin. Und das ist natürlich auch zeitkritisch. Und man muss vor allem auch kurzfristig irgendwie sagen, okay, das ist jetzt so der Bereich. Und ich stelle mir halt vor, man hätte jetzt so einen Paparazzi-Notkoffer im Gepäck, so wie man eine Sauerstoffflasche und Verbandmaterial dabei hat, macht das Ding irgendwie auf und sagt, okay, jetzt hier auf der Karte, von da nach da nach da, da fliegst du jetzt mal los, zack, ich schmeiße das Ding in den Wind. Und eine Viertelstunde später habe ich irgendwie eine Hi-Res-Karte auf meinem Laptop, wo ich irgendwie rumscrollen kann und schauen kann. Ist das unrealistisch?
Ich glaube, der Überblick, den kann man besser machen. Ich glaube, es ist mehr so für die Vorort dann zu schauen. Also wirklich große Strecken abzufliegen mit so einem Elektroflugzeug ist vielleicht nicht so gut. Aber ich denke, mal eben schnell, da ist jetzt ein großes ganzer Stadtteil oder ein Gebiet von Häusern, wo ich jetzt mal gucken will, wie kaputt ist das da, macht das sicherlich schon Sinn. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Flugzeug auf Island jetzt deponiert, eins von diesen metrologischen. Da haben wir so einen Staubsensor mal eingebaut, der so ähnlich funktioniert wie so ein Rauchmelder, den du so unter die Decke schraubst. Und der ist jetzt einfach da. Und wenn da demnächst nochmal wieder irgendwas passiert, dann können die den da an der Universität auspacken und können da einfach mitfliegen. Also das...
Also das ist so eine Aerosole zu messen jetzt nach Vulkanausbruch oder sowas?
Ja, so nicht sehr präzise. Also du hast dann so ganz grob die Konzentration, aber um halt diese Messung schnell machen zu können.
Wie verhalten sich denn eure Flieger in Vulkanasche?
Haben wir noch nicht ausprobiert, aber...
Mal dieser Abschleifeffekt, der so befürchtet wird bei den Flugzeugen und Verstopfung von Düsen, weiß nicht, fällt ja wahrscheinlich nicht so ins Gewicht, oder? Bei niedrigen Geschwindigkeiten und so.
Wir verbrennen ja nichts, wir haben keine Luft. Du hast sicherlich Kugellager in dem Motor, wo das reingeraten könnte, aber das könnte man ja auch noch ein bisschen dicht machen. Ist vielleicht ein bisschen kritisch von der Kühlung, aber grundsätzlich, denke ich, hätten wir weit weniger Probleme als irgendein Verbrennungsmotor, der ja irgendwie sich Luft reinholen muss und das verbrennen würde. Gar keine Turbine oder so.
Da wäre natürlich der Radius auch wieder ganz interessant.
Ja, aber da wäre es wahrscheinlich auch wieder das Vertikale, was der Trick wäre. Dass du halt durch die Aerosole hochfliegst und mal so ein Profil bildest und guckst, wie viel ist denn da eigentlich. Was die auch immer gerne machen oder mal machen würden, wäre, dass sie die Partikel einsammeln. Aber das ist mechanisch dann mit Vakuum pumpen und irgendwo hin und Deckel drauf. Das ist ein bisschen aufwendiger. Das ist mit so einem 600 Gramm Styropor-Flieger nichts zu machen. Aber in der Richtung gucken wir auch, was wir vielleicht...
Das Ding mal so über ein Vulkan rüberzuschmeißen und dadurch die Staubwolke fliegen zu lassen. Ich drehe total durch. Das ist irgendwie vielseitig. Weiß nicht, gibt es da noch so andere Anwendungen in der Hinsicht? Waldbrände sind ja auch immer solche Bedrohungen.
Es gab an der ENAG mal ein Projekt in Südfrankreich. Da ist man ja auch von Waldbränden geplagt. Da gab es ein großes, groß angekündigtes Projekt mit der Feuerwehr. Und da sollte dann ein Waldgebiet gesperrt werden und die Flugsicherung. Und das war riesengroß. Am Ende war es dann so ein Lagerfeuer, was man dann angemacht hat, was dann nicht wirklich feststellbar war mit dem Flugzeug. Also man hat da einfache Kohlenmonoxid-Sensoren gehabt und hat auch in der Flugprogrammiersprache das so programmiert, dass er halt immer der Konzentration folgt, um halt den Quell des Feuers zu finden. Das funktionierte auch in der Simulation wunder prima und hätte vielleicht bei einem richtigen Brand auch funktioniert. Aber mit so einem kleinen Brand, da sind die Sensoren einfach zu schlecht und die Verteilung ist so groß, dass du das nicht wirklich feststellen konntest.
Aber in der ganzen Geschichte ist eine Menge Musik drin, habe ich so den Eindruck. Also man kann sich immer wieder neue Kombinationen überlegen und letzten Endes ist es nur eine Frage der Kreativität, wo man da einen Anwendungsfall findet. Was zeichnet sich jetzt so unmittelbar ab, worüber jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so gesprochen haben, so an Anwendungsfällen, die dir noch einfallen würden, jenseits der Rettungsproblematik vielleicht?
Also diese Metrologie verlässt jetzt so den Punkt, dass die Leute damit experimentieren, sondern es wird so, dass man das einfach mitnimmt. Also es gibt zwei Teams, die sich darauf vorbereiten, das in der Antarktis einzusetzen, jetzt zum Jahreswechsel. Und da haben wir jetzt so diesen Experiment hier. Und wir gucken mal, ob das überhaupt geht, verlassen. Und das scheint jetzt so, sich so ein bisschen, ein klein bisschen zu etablieren, dass man das als Ballon-Alternative einfach so dabei hat. Wir haben jetzt mit Leuten in Australien gesprochen, die über Korallen fliegen möchten und Messungen machen mit diesem metrologischen Flugzeug. Also es gibt eine Menge Leute, die lustige Ideen haben, wo man überall sonst nicht günstig hingekommen ist, was man bisher nicht so machen konnte. Wichtig ist ja auch nicht nur, dass man irgendetwas zum ersten Mal macht, dass man das erste Mal in der Arktis, in der Antarktis, vom Eisbrecher aus oder sonst irgendwas, sondern dass man da so ein bisschen Konstanz reinbringt. Das ist ja nichts, was man nicht früher auch schon konnte. Man kann ja auch einen Temperatursensor, eine Chessner laden, irgendwo hin und damit rumfliegen.
Ja, aber günstig und zuverlässig.
Und vom Doktoranden selber zu steuern. Das ist halt so der Trick. Und das Ideale ist eigentlich, dass sich so eine Metrologen oder auch Archäologen, Archäologen gibt, die halt auch gerne Aufnahmen von oben machen möchten, die haben auch so Ballons, das ist auch ein bisschen wackelig, dass die sich dann so eine technische Fakultät schnappen, sich das Paparazzi runterladen und dann zusammen das tun. Das ist eigentlich so das Ideal ist. Da haben beide Spaß dran, beide haben was davon. Und du hast halt eine sehr günstige und trotzdem zuverlässige Möglichkeit, um einfach Daten zu sammeln, die du so nicht sammeln konntest, nicht weil es nicht ging, aber weil es so günstig und zuverlässig eben nicht funktioniert hat.
Worüber wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, ist die Tatsache, dass es hierbei ja um ein Open-Source-Projekt handelt, sowohl in der Hardware als auch in der Software.
Richtig, ja. Das ist alles sowohl Hardware als auch Software, als in NGPL 2.
Das heißt, kann man nehmen, kann man verändern, kann man einsetzen, wie man möchte, eine Änderung macht und man bringt sie in den Umlauf, dann muss man auch den Source Code hinterher schmeißen, das Übliche. Das heißt, es ist auch davon auszugehen, dass sich schon eine ganz beträchtliche Community drum herum entwickelt hat. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt von drei Leuten gesprochen, das sind deutlich mehr, die sich damit auseinandersetzen, oder?
Es ist schwierig zu sagen, wie viel wirklich damit fliegen, aber ich denke, das sind so 500 bis 1.000, die sich so ein System mal gebaut haben und damit arbeiten. Es passiert immer wieder, dass man irgendwo mit jemandem spricht und dann sagt, hier, Paparazzi wäre doch auch was für euch. Und die dann sagen, ja, das haben wir schon mal, das haben wir auch, das ist super. Also es gibt verschiedene, es gibt die Hobbyleute, aus dem Bereich kommt es ja ursprünglich. Ganz am Anfang war das noch nicht an der Universität, sondern fand so als Hobbyprojekt statt. Ist dann in die Universität, an die ENAC, école nationale, aviation civile, reingegangen. Und das ist auch so das Home, der Home-Bereich, da wo so alles...
Da ist auch der Home-Patch des Projektes, paparazzi.enac.fr.
Und dann gibt es eben auch Firmen, die versuchen, da Produkte zu machen mit Paparazzi. Mal offen, mal sagen sie das nicht so. Also Thales ist auch so eine Militärfirma aus Frankreich. Die haben das auch mal einfach so verwendet und als Iris verkauft. Fanden wir nicht so toll. Es gibt Firmen, es gibt Hobbyleute, es gibt Universitäten. Also es gibt sehr viele, eine sehr breite Anwendung. Und Leute machen sehr unterschiedliche Sachen damit. Und das ist sehr stark konfigurierbar, was es für manche vielleicht schwierig macht, da einzusteigen. Also es gibt nicht so diese eine Anwendung und so eine Anleitung im Internet, das stecke ich da dran und so und hier und da. Sondern es ist so breit konfigurierbar für Quadcopter, für Flächenflugzeuge. Wir haben diese drei Hardware-Plattformen, die alle noch unterstützt werden. Das macht es.
Also es ist mehr so ein Werkzeugkasten für Autopiloten.
Genau.
Und so viele, die es werden wollen.
Auch so ein kompletter Baukasten, dass du nicht nur das Flugzeug fliegen kannst, sondern du hast auch die kompletten Tools dabei, um jetzt Messwerte zu verarbeiten. Du hast einen neuen Feuchtigkeitssensor gekauft, dann schreibst du irgendwie 20 Zeilen Code, um den auszulesen, baust das in so einen Modul-Baukasten ein, definierst eine Nachricht, Feuchtigkeit, Temperatur sowieso und dann macht das gesamte System das für dich. Es sorgt dafür, dass die Daten runtergeschickt werden, dass du die anzeigen lassen kannst, dass du die visualisieren kannst, dass die in Lockfile geschrieben werden.
Selbstbeschreibend sind, etc.
Genau. Das ist alles so ein Komplettpaket und eben auch dafür gedacht, dass du es schon wissenschaftlich einsetzt. Also du kannst nicht nur einfach rumfliegen, sondern auch die Messwerte sammeln. Du kannst dann auch in den Flugplan, wenn Feuchtigkeit höher, 90 Prozent dann sofort zurückkommen, weil Nebel oder so. Das kannst du alles direkt einbauen, ohne selber Software schreiben zu müssen.
Und in was ist das alles schon so eingebaut worden? Sind das jetzt wirklich nur die kleinen Styropor-Flugzeuge, mit denen du so arbeitest, oder hat da auch schon mal jemand ein bisschen mehr Geld in die Hand genommen? Man könnte ja auch so ein richtiges Flugzeug nehmen. Ich meine, das ist ja auch am Ende nichts anderes, oder?
Die Idee gab es mal in Kanada, dass wir jemanden, da hatte jemand ein Experimentalflugzeug, das ist ein selbstgebautes Flugzeug, wo er ohnehin machen durfte, was er wollte. Da haben wir dann aber irgendwie, ist das im Sand verlaufen. Also da jemanden, ein Menschen mit unserer Software, das ist dann doch ein bisschen...
Ach so, richtig, gleich mit Mensch drin. Look ma, I can fly with GPL-Software.
Das größte ist, glaube ich, so 25 Kilo. Das ist auch so eine Gesetzesgrenze, wo du dann das Flugzeug zulassen musst. Zwar nur bei dem Modellbauverein, aber du musst es dann zulassen.
25 Kilo. Und auf was kommt ihr so mit euren Styroporflugzeugen?
Der Standardflieger wiegt so 600 Gramm.
Okay, also das ist schon mal eine Menge Luft. Ich meine, das bedeutet ja auch, man könnte mehr Akku, stärkere Motoren, etc. Gleich mehr Reichweite oder ist das nämlich Mädchenrechnung?
Ja, aber dann musst du auch wieder mehr Gerät in die Arktis bringen und das geht eher kaputt. Oder wenn es runterfällt, geht es eher kaputt. Also das ist schon so.
Ja gut, aber das muss ja nicht immer gleich in die Arktis gehen.
Ja, aber es kommt drauf an, was du machen möchtest. Also 25-Kilo-Flieger, die haben Infrarot-Kameras, um Grünflächen zu filmen und zu gucken, wie sich da das Gestreuch verändert. Das ändert sich dann im Infrarotbereich. Da brauchst du halt so große Kameras, da muss das Flugzeug so schwer sein. Der Feuchtigkeitssensor, der wiegt irgendwie anderthalb Gramm. Und um den da hochzubringen, brauchst du keine 25-Kilo-Flugzeug. Also du musst immer so gucken, was willst du machen, wo willst du hin.
Ja gut, aber High-Res-Fotografie zum Beispiel, das ist, wo man auch ein amtliches Objektiv dran haben will, also wo man wirklich viel Licht einfangen will, wo man eine hohe Auflösung hat, um einfach wirklich im Detail zu beobachten.
Das wäre kein Problem, da auch ein größeres Flugzeug, auch 25-Kilo-Flugzeug zu nehmen. Also es gibt diese Infrarot-Kameras.
Das macht schon Bumm, ja. Aber das gab es jetzt so noch nicht. Was ist denn so das Größte, was der so...
Universität Stuttgart hat diese 25-Kilo-Flieger gebaut, mit diesen verschiedenen Infrarot-Kameras.
Ach so, okay.
Und das war dann auch mit Paparazzi. Die kalibrieren ihre Satelliten damit. Also die bauen eigentlich Satelliten. Und die machen halt so Infrarot-Aufnahmen. Und das müssen sie halt irgendwie kalibrieren, weil sich das verändert. Und dann fliegen sie mit ihrem Modellflugzeug da rüber.
Das heißt, sie bilden quasi Referenzdaten. Und wenn der Satellit dann das Gleiche sieht, dann ist gut. Oder zumindest, wenn sie auf dieselbe Berechnung kommen. Pff, ich... Auch eine interessante Anwendung. Und wo geht es jetzt hin? Was ist so... Was sind so die Herausforderungen? Ich meine, dass alles fliegt?
Das ist jetzt so...
Das ist technisch schon so weit fertig, dass man jetzt gar keine Wünsche mehr hat. Und mein Fledermauswunsch wird einfach ignoriert. Ich finde das ja cool, weil man das Ding wirklich einfach so mit Spackes in irgendwie so eine Felsspalte reinschmeißen kann. Und er ist einfach da wirklich in der Lage, da in Realtime links, rechts und so. Ja, zum Beispiel da bei Star Wars, dieses Mal bei Teil 1, wo man da irgendwie...
Also für uns ist gerade so, der Trick, das so in die Breite zu bringen, dass wenn Leute auf uns zukommen, sagen, wir würden das auch gern machen, dass wir denen die Sensoren entsprechend anbinden, dass wir denen die Flugzeuge bauen, dass wir denen das beibiegen, dass wir vielleicht auch mal bei einer Mission dabei sind. Also es ist mehr so...
Mehr so ein Plug-and-Play-Zustand, Herr Rastell.
Alltagsgeschäft jetzt. Also es passiert nicht so unfassbar viel Neues. Jetzt so mit diesen metrologischen Sachen. Da kommt immer mal wieder ein Sensor dazu. Jetzt bei dieser französischen Messkampagne hatten wir zum Beispiel einen Sensor, der einfach die elektrostatische Spannung gemessen hat. Also einfach ein Operationsverstärker, der sehr hochohmig ist, der einfach die Ladung misst. Dann wurde das Flugzeug in Alu eingepackt und dann kam irgendwo so ein Messingteil raus und dann wurde da die Ladung gemessen. Und dann sind wir damit in den blauen Himmel rausgeflogen und haben dann quasi indirekt oder haben indirekt über die Ladung messen können, wie viele Partikel in der Luft sind, weil die das Flugzeug dann doch aufladen, so wie mit Luftballon auf Pullover reiben. Und konnten dann feststellen, wo in der Atmosphäre die Inversionsschicht ist, also wo die Temperatur dann wieder höher wurde, weil die ganzen Partikel da unter gefangen waren. Und das ist so, das macht Spaß. Wenn du so am Sommernachmittag im blauen Himmel hochguckst, denkst du, das ist ja total unspannend. Und dann fliegst du dann beim Flugzeug durch und siehst, dass da doch ziemlich spannende Sachen passieren. Das ist so gerade der Trick, so die verschiedenen Sensoren reintun und mit den Leuten da Messungen zu machen.
Aber so im Bereich Flugsteuerung selber wird gerade gar nicht so viel geforscht?
Es gibt eine Menge neuer Sensoren, ein bisschen ein Problem sind Vibrationen. Du hast einen Beschleunigungssensor und auch Vibrationen sind Beschleunigung. Und diese Vibrationssensoren sind ja letztlich auch wie Mikrofone. Die nehmen das dann auch wahr. Da kannst du mechanisch ein bisschen was machen, das in Schaumstoff einpacken oder in Silikonkissen oder irgendwie sowas. Aber wenn dir dann ein Stückchen Propeller abbricht, hast du doch wieder heftige Vibrationen und möchtest dann, wenn du 15 Kilometer weg bist, vermeiden, dass das Flugzeug dann deswegen runterfällt. Und da gibt es noch Entwicklungen zuzusehen, dass die Sensoren besser werden.
Also dass das Ding so ein bisschen fehlertoleranter wird. Wie wissen wir das? Wenn man jetzt so ein Flügel abknickt, kann er das ausgleichen? Ist die Software an der Stelle... Also bei den Quadrocoptern ist das ja auch so, ne? Ist ein Propeller weg, dann ist die Software dann in der Lage, das vielleicht noch auszugleichen, zumindest bei diesen 8-fach Dingern oder wie viele Propeller man eben auch hat. Also wie viel kann man dem zusetzen, dass er sich noch hält?
Also grundsätzlich mal der Quadcopter kann das noch ausgleichen, wenn er 8 zum Beispiel hat und einer ausfällt. Aber wenn jetzt in der Sensorik oder in elektrischer Versorgung irgendwas ausfällt, dann fällt er runter. Das macht der Flächenflieger ja erstmal nicht. Wenn da der Strom ausfällt, dann segelt er erstmal weiter. Das macht es häufig einfacher, wenn man Genehmigungen einholen muss. Wir haben Ende letzten Jahres oder im Herbst letzten Jahres mal probiert, ob wir das hinbekommen, dass wir ein Stückchen Tragfläche abwerfen und den Autopiloten darauf trainieren, dass er dann trotzdem noch weiter fliegt. Da gibt es auch ein Video von, da haben wir einfach ein Drittel von der Fläche so mechanisch abwerfbar gemacht, dass der das wirklich rauswirft. Dann war das ein zweimotoriges Flugzeug. Dann schaltet er auch noch den Motor auf der Seite aus. Wir simulieren nicht nur die abgefallene Tragfläche, sondern auch noch den Ausfall des Motors. In manuell kannst du das Flugzeug dann eigentlich gar nicht mehr fliegen. Selbst unser bester Pilot hatte dann arge Schwierigkeiten, ein so unsymmetrisch gewohntes Flugzeug überhaupt noch in der Luft zu halten. Der Autopilot hat das eigentlich ohne Probleme hinbekommen. Wir hatten das sogar im Sommer. In Frankreich waren wir auf einem normalen Modellflugplatz zusammen mit den Leuten von ENAC oder so, die Paparazzi-Leute. Und da kam so ein Junge auf uns zu und meinte, ich bin gerade in euch reingeflogen und tut mir leid. Und wir guckten so hoch und das Flugzeug flog da so seine Kreise. Und ich so, nö, nö, ist schon okay, ist schon okay, ist nichts passiert. Und dann landete der Junge und kam dann mit seinem Flugzeug. Und das war so ein weißes Glasfaserflugzeug, wo überall so rote Striemen drauf waren. Ich so, doch, ich bin wirklich in euch reingeflogen. Ja, okay, ja, wir können ja mal landen. Dann sind wir so zur Landung und dann hat Christian dann den Hebel umgelegt, um das in Auto eins, also diese stabilisierte. Und da ging das schon kaum nicht. Und dann in manuell noch viel weniger. Und dann haben wir es so gerade hingekriegt, das Flugzeug dann in diesen automatischen Modus zu landen. Und dann sah man, dass der Junge da auf der anderen Seite, also da, wo man es nicht abgeworfen hat, zwischen Tragfläche und der Steuerfläche reingeschlagen ist. Und das Querruder ist also hochgeklappt. Und das ist also, war komplett zerstört. Aber der Autopilot hat das komplett ausgeglichen. Und du hast einfach seine Kreise geflogen.
Okay, also es ist extrem resistent.
Man kann es resistent machen. Also das ist zusätzliche Regelung. Und er versucht dann nochmal zu bestimmen, wie sehr er wohl aus der Null rausgebracht wurde, und das zu korrigieren. Mit dieser Software fliegen wir aber normalerweise nicht, weil das wieder Instabilitäten, die wir im normalen Flug nicht so wollen, mit reinbringen.
Und wie ist das so mit den Sensoren? Wie zuverlässig sind die Sensoren? Wäre es nicht auch vorstellbar, wenn Messungen jetzt mal wirklich, wirklich wichtig sind? Ich meine eigentlich sind alle Messungen wichtig. Aber wenn man an der Stelle fehlertolerant sein will, dass man alles doppelt auslegt, wird das gemacht?
Eher nicht.
Oder vielleicht eine Fehlererkennung in irgendeiner Form?
Das Einzige, was wir jetzt in Hardware doppelt auslegen, ist, dass wir die Funkstrecke eben doppelt haben, dass wir eine RC-Verbindung haben von dem normalen Sender und eine Verbindung zum Laptop. Und wenn das Flugzeug, wenn jetzt das RC ausfallen würde, der normale Sender, dass man das auch über einen Joystick, über einen Laptop fliegen könnte. Also diese Funkstrecke, die ist halt doppelt. Ansonsten ist so die Idee, dass die Hardware nur einmal da ist, weil alles, was nicht an Bord ist, kann auch keinem auf den Kopf fallen. Und die Sicherheit, die du zusätzlich gewinnst, indem du jetzt einen zweiten GPS einbaust oder so was, die ist viel geringer als den Aufwand, drauf zu finden, wer macht dir eigentlich gerade Unsinn oder das Zusatzgewicht, was du da drin hast. Du hast in der Software vielleicht an der einen oder anderen Stelle noch mal so eine Plausibilitätsprüfung, um zu gucken, ob das, was ich da gerade messe, auch Sinn macht. Aber es ist relativ schwierig, überhaupt so einen Fehler zu entdecken oder dann überhaupt zu verstehen, was da passiert ist. Wir hatten das, als wir auf Spitzbergen waren, waren wir auf 1500 Metern und der Motor ging aus und er segelte wieder runter. Es war der fünfte Tag in Folge, wo wir stundenlang geflogen sind.
Was heißt, der Motor ging aus?
Wir machen den dann aus. Der fliegt hoch, fliegt oben, zwei Kreise, dann wird der Motor ausgemacht und segelt wieder runter.
Also er weiß, dass er jetzt sozusagen ohne Motor fliegen soll.
Genau.
Dann ist er wie ein Segelflieger.
Genau, und dann segelt er so relativ sportlich runter.
Er kann ja auch wie so ein Segelflieger fliegen. Wäre das nicht mal was Schönes mit den Thermosensoren, dass man dann auch wirklich so die Thermik sucht und sich wie so ein Segelflieger verhält und ganz ohne Motor auch fliegt, dass man quasi ein autonomes Segelflugzeug draus macht? Das ist doch eigentlich so der Sport.
Ja, aber nochmal zu dem Flugzeug. Das ist ja mehr so ein Düsenflugzeug, wie das aussieht. Das ist ja schmale Stummelflügel und so, ist nicht wirklich dafür gebaut, um zu segeln. Und plötzlich schlägt das aber wieder. Und dann sitzt du da, guckst auf den Monitor und denkst, was ist jetzt hier los? Und du guckst auf den Motor, der Motor ist aus. Du guckst auf die Batteriespannung, die sagt dir auch, dass der Motor aus sein muss, weil die Batteriespannung so hoch ist. Du guckst auf die Lage, das Flugzeug ist auch angestochen, soll auch runtergehen. Und trotzdem steigt das. Es ist Abend, es kann keine Thermik sein, im Eis ist sowieso keine Thermik. Es ist ein bisschen Wind und du verstehst das nicht mehr. Und das hast du halt hin und wieder mal, dass irgendwas passiert, was du überhaupt nicht verstehst, was deine Software macht oder deine Hardware. Oder in dem Fall war das halt so, dass der Wind über die Berge, da in Spitzbergen drüber gepustet hat, unten aufgedotzt ist und wieder hochging und so eine Mountain-Wave gebildet hat.
Das ist ein Föhn-Effekt. Das ist Föhn, fast nicht.
Das ist Föhn, wenn es dann runterkommt und warm wird, glaube ich. Aber da dotzt es wirklich auf und geht wieder hoch. Und du hast dann da so einen sehr lokalen Aufwind. Und dann ist unser Flugzeug da gesurft. Und das haben wir dann erstmal nicht verstanden. Und jetzt dann noch in der Software richtig darauf zu reagieren, das ist halt relativ schwierig. Und deswegen haben wir solche Sachen eher nicht drin. Die versuchen jetzt auch, Fehler auf Fehler zu reagieren. Okay, dann machen wir einfach was.
Was ist jetzt mit der Segelflieger-Idee? Also, Angelo Mann würde jetzt vielleicht auch wirklich mal so... Gibt ja sicherlich diese Modelle auch als Segelflieger-Variante, oder? Wäre das vorstellbar, oder gibt es sowas schon, dass man dann auch wirklich quasi diesen... Wo ist die Thermik? Dass man dann auch versucht, vielleicht den Segelflieger so ein bisschen zu emulieren. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die arbeiten. Ich meine, die schauen sich das Wetter an. Die haben irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht auch meteorologische Informationen. Aber im Wesentlichen geht es ja darum, diese Auftriebsorte zu erkennen. Man sieht einfach, wie es da hinten aussieht, um die Wolkenkonstellation, la la la. Da könnte es warm sein, da fliege ich mal hin. Und dann ist es warm und dann treibt es es eben nach oben. Hältst du das für... Also ist die Software, ist euer Projekt für sowas überhaupt denkbar?
Also Segelflieger haben so einen Sensor, der ihnen zeigt, ob sie steigt oder fallen, das akustisch. Darüber bekommen die mit, ob das Flugzeug irgendwie steigt oder fällt.
Und was misst der?
Der müsste einfach das steigen und das fallen über den Luftdruck.
Luftdruck, okay.
Aber ich meine, das wäre einfach Luftdruck. Früher waren das so Druckdosen.
Habt ihr auch einen Luftdruck-Sensor?
Wir haben auch einen Luftdruck-Sensor. Wir bekommen das aber auch über das GPS.
Na ja, okay, gut.
Wir können das feststellen. Wir sind im Sommer auf der Wasserkuppe geflogen. Das ist so ein Modellbau Eldorado, wo viele Modellflieger dann da auch in der Thermek fliegen. Und da haben wir das mal probiert, mit einem kleinen Segelflugzeug auch Thermek zu finden. Und das sieht man dann auch. Also wir sind in einem großen Kreis geflogen. Und dann hast du gesehen, dass da an der Stelle ging es immer hoch und an der anderen ging es immer wieder runter. Das Problem ist dann eher, dass das Flugzeug autonom nicht so kleine Kreise fliegen kann, dass du in diesen Thermek-Schläuchen wirklich aufsteigen kannst. Also die Thermek-Schläuche sind dann an der Stelle nicht so groß gewesen, dass wir da überhaupt, also der kleinste Kreis, den wir mit dem Flugzeug fliegen konnten, das waren so 40, 50 Meter Radius. Und diese Blase war einfach kleiner als das. Das heißt, du konntest da nicht so richtig einkreisen, um dann da hoch zu gehen. Aber grundsätzlich könnte man das machen.
Ja, aber ich meine, da wo jetzt ein richtiger Segelflieger hochgeht, das sind ja auch größere Thermek-Schläuche, oder?
Ja, aber die gehen auch ganz schön. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß die sonst sind oder ob die vielleicht größer werden nach oben hin. Also wir haben das mal so ausprobiert, das Schienen zu funktionieren, aber wir haben da jetzt nicht wirklich Energie reingesteckt.
Okay, aber Uncharted Territory, immerhin.
Es gibt Leute im Netz, die das versuchen, die sich das angucken und versuchen, Software zu schreiben, dass du erstmal so eine Map machst, wo geht es wie hoch, und dann fliegst du dahin und nutzt das auch.
Solarantrieb? Kann man so mit den Flächen da irgendwas reißen?
Solarflieger sind immer so, dass sie mit der Energie, die sie auf der Fläche einfangen, gerade so in der Luft bleiben können. Das hast du ja über die letzten 20, 30 Jahre gesehen, dass das immer, das waren keine schnellen Flieger, sondern die sind immer so, und wenn zu viel Wind war, konnten sie nicht fliegen. Und wo Metrologen fliegen, jetzt für die Anwendung, ist es dann zu windig dafür. Und Murat hat seine Doktorarbeit zusammen mit Paparazzi darüber gemacht, so ein Langfliegflugzeug zu bauen im Prinzip. Und für den war am Ende klar, dass es sich lohnt, eher das Gewicht, das du in die Solarzellen stecken würdest, noch in Akkus zu stecken und mitzuführen, als dass du das in Solarzellen reintust. Also dessen Aufgabe war, von Corsica nach Saint-Tropez zu fliegen. Das sind so 200 irgendwas Kilometer. Das war so seine selbstgestellte Aufgabe. Da hat er ein kleines Elektroflugzeug gebaut und hat das dann genau durchgerechnet. Und das hat sich nicht gelohnt, auch die besten Solarzellen, die er in Frankreich von der Raumfahrt bekommen konnte, da einzubauen. Sondern es war lohner, einfach zusätzliche Akkus reinzutun und das dann zu versuchen.
Na gut, aber mit Akkus ist ja dann trotzdem irgendwann mal Ende. Wenn ich mir jetzt so überlege, vielleicht gibt es ja diese Challenge auch schon so around the world, dass man einfach einen autonomen Flieger baut, der einfach darauf ausgelegt ist, einfach alles, was sich irgendwie anbietet, weiter zu fliegen, zu nutzen. Sei es Thermik, sei es eben Energieerzeugung. Ich bin total maximal leicht. Es geht jetzt auch nicht darum, er soll einfach nur fliegen. Er muss sonst irgendwie gar nichts tun.
Das ist immer noch so der Traum, dass man den Atlantik mit dem elektrisch angetriebenen Flugzeug, das fernbeferne Ziel, das irgendwann mal zu machen. Mit dem Benzinmotor hat man das schon vor 2002, 2004 oder so gemacht. Oder 2001. Und das mit einem elektrischen Flieger hinzukriegen, das wäre...
Wie weit kommen denn diese Segelflieger? Ich meine, die Profis, die legen ja auch schon beträchtliche Strecken zurück.
Ja, da kannst du einige tausend Kilometer, das ist, glaube ich, so ein Dreiecksflug einmal quer durch Europa. Da hast du dann einmal das Problem Atlantik, da hast du keine Thermik. Überm Wasser ist alles gleich, da geht es nicht hoch. Und langen Strecken zu fliegen, hast du das Problem, dass du die Genehmigung dafür brauchst. Und das ist in Europa schwierig, auch in den USA relativ schwierig. Das geht gut in der Antarktis oder vielleicht, wenn man die Verbindung hat auf Island oder auch in den Spitzbergen. Aber jetzt so einen richtig langen Flug zu machen, von Corsica zum Festland, das klappt da auch nur, weil man da sich kennt. Und in Frankreich ist das vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen einfacher, wenn man sich da als Universität und so das dann mal machen möchte. Aber das Haupthindernis ist heutzutage, dass du es nicht erlaubt bekommst, das zu tun.
Wir haben jetzt schon mit dem Terroristen im roten T-Shirt eingestiegen und so dieses etwas merkwürdige Verhältnis zu militärischer Anwendung. Wenn man sich mit sowas beschäftigt, klopft The Dark Side, Offensive Force da häufiger mal an. Man könnte mir ja schon diverse Szenarien vorstellen, auch jenseits von Militär und Überwachung. You will help me build aircraft. Ja, so irgendwie in Mexiko gibt es da sicherlich auch interessante Nachfragen nach Drohnen. Ist das irgendwie ein Thema auch? Redet man da in der Community darüber? Gibt es da einen Codex? Das übertreibe ich jetzt einfach nur.
Ja, also ich glaube die machen eher in U-Booten als in Flugzeugen. So the dark side. Es gibt dann auch immer Leute aus der Axis of Evil, die dann da auf den Konferenzen auch rumlaufen. Einmal ist jemand rumgegangen und hat gefragt nach den Spannweiten und hat dann aus dem Mittelwert die ideale Spannweite eines Flugzeugs berechnet. Wenn das auf so einer Ebene stattfindet, dann ja, also eigentlich nicht. Und der Schutz wäre ja dann auch einfach zu sagen, hier, da ist Open Source, mach doch. Und ich glaube, ich glaube, das brauchen aber auch die nicht. Also ich glaube damals war das bei Saddam Hussein, die hatten auch so Modellflugzeuge, haben da auch irgendwie, gab es auch mal so Bilder. Im Iran gibt es Flugzeuge, wenn man das mal, wenn man in dem Bereich mal bleiben möchte. Ich glaube, die brauchen die Hilfe da an der Stelle auch nicht, um das machen zu können. Und es war am Anfang immer ein Argument, wenn man irgendwo einen Vortrag gemacht hatte, aber unterstützt ihr da nicht die Terroristen, wenn ihr nach ihnen sucht, im roten T-Shirt. Aber glaube ich eher nicht. Also ich glaube, man kann mit dem Gewehr sehr viel mehr anstellen.
Als mit dem Styropor-Flugzeug.
Als mit dem Styropor-Flugzeug, was man dann auch noch irgendwie dazu bringen muss, das zu tun, was man möchte. Von daher...
Wenn jetzt einer Blut gelegt hat hier bei dem Thema, wie kann man denn hier mitmachen? Wo gibt es die Ressourcen? Und vor allem, wo gibt es vielleicht auch so die Veranstaltungen und Orte, wo man auch mal an diese Szene ganz konkret andocken kann?
Es gibt dieses Paparazzi-EDAC-FR.
Ein dickes Wiki ist das.
Ein riesengroßes Wiki. Leider ein bisschen zerstreut. Also wenn da jemand mal muss, hätte das alles mal ein bisschen zusammenzuführen, wäre das sicherlich auch von Vorteil. Da gibt es irgendwo ein Git, da ist die ganze Software drin. Wir haben so einen Hauptgit, wo die ganze Repositorie, wo die ganze Software drinsteckt. Für Flächenflugzeuge, für Quadcopter, da sind auch die ganzen Flugpläne von Island oder vom Eisbrecher drin. Da könnte man also gleich wieder hinfahren und genau das sich wieder abfliegen. Es gibt einen IRC-Kanal, wo recht viel passiert. Das Wichtigste ist wahrscheinlich so eine alte klassische, oder die alte klassische Mailing-Liste, wo man sich trifft. Es gibt einmal im Jahr irgendwo eine Konferenz. Die ist nächstes Jahr wieder in Braunschweig. Da ist so ein bisschen das Problem, dass das unter Umständen recht viel Geld kostet, da teilzunehmen. Aber vielleicht kann man sich da auch im Umfeld nochmal treffen. Wer heißt die Veranstaltung? Inzwischen heißt sie EMUF, International Micro Aerial Vehicle. Und dann gibt es noch die Moto Drone. Die ist so 2008, glaube ich, das erste Mal entstanden. 2007 waren wir beim Kongress und haben da was über Paparazzi erzählt. Und im Nachgang ist dann irgendwie Moto Drone entstanden. Vielleicht ist das dann ein Punkt, um da mal zusammenzukommen. Da haben wir uns auch von Anfang an beteiligt, waren dabei. Und haben da versucht, uns einzubringen oder Paparazzi den Leuten näherzubringen, was auch eine Menge Leute dann letztlich da motiviert hat teilzunehmen.
Ja, Martin, haben wir noch irgendwas Großartiges unerwähnt gelassen? Sonst noch irgendwelche Ermutigungen von deiner Seite?
Einfach mal mitmachen.
Ich meine, das ist einfach ein spannendes Feld. Das Schöne an solchen Sachen ist, es ist einfach wunderbar greifbar. Ich meine, man sieht und spürt richtig sofort die Auswirkungen. Und wenn mir schon die Kreativität hier durchgeht, zumindest die Vorstellungskraft, was theoretisch möglich wäre, dann lässt sich das ja vielleicht auch mit anderen Projekten gut vergleichen. Na gut, dann haben wir es jetzt. Das war es, CRE187 und vielen Dank, Martin, für die Ausführungen hier über Paparazzi. Über den Namen haben wir gar nicht geredet, aber das lassen wir jetzt einfach mal so stehen. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.